the same why i go to
and so i'm looking forward to that
because you know
he has to he sets scenes on streets that
i travel every day so i want to i want
to see what george has done
tell us what you're reading this summer
send us a tweet at book tv
now on book tv encore book notes iris
chang was on book notes in 1997 to talk
about her book the rape of nan king the
forgotten holocaust of world war ii it
documents the atrocities upon the people
of nanking by the japanese military
during the early years of world war ii
it's about an hour
irish chang author of the rape of nan
king the forgotten holocaust of world
war ii
when did you first think about writing
this book
well
it goes back a long way i mean i learned
about this event when i was a little
child but i really didn't think about
writing the book until i finished my
first one thread of the silkworm and
after i had attended a conference in
california that was devoted to
preserving the history of this event
what was the rape of mankind the rape of
nan king is one of the greatest
atrocities of world history in december
of 1937 the japanese swept into the
capital of china which was then nan king
and within six to eight weeks they
butchered raped and tortured hundreds of
thousands of chinese civilians three
hundred thousand people ultimately died
during this massacre and they raped uh
an estimated two
let's see twenty thousand to eighty
thousand women during this period why is
there such a discrepancy between twenty
thousand and eighty thousand it's often
very difficult to ascertain the exact
number and many women were reluctant to
come out with these
these facts at the time
i'm looking at page 59 and there's a
gentleman here by the name of nakatomi
hakudo who who was he or who is he well
he he was a doctor he's a doctor now but
back in 1937 he was one of the soldiers
who committed atrocities in nan king and
there is a uh i'm going to read
something here just a moment but
have you met him
no no i mean this this is taken um from
from an article but uh the story was
just so compelling that i had to put in
my book before i read this tell me what
the story is
well he was in
uh are we talking about the story in the
article itself well the story about him
now he's a shrine
he's a doctor he's a doctor now and he
feels
so terrible about what he did so he has
put
pictures of the i guess some of the
atrocities in the waiting room of of his
clinic and um so patience of his can see
what he did in name king
let me read just a little bit from what
you've got in your book i remember being
driven in a truck along a path that had
been cleared through piles of thousands
and thousands of slaughtered bodies wild
dogs were gnawing at the dead flesh as
we stopped and pulled a group of chinese
prisoners out of the back
then the japanese officer proposed a
test of my courage he unsheathed his
sword spat on it and with a sudden
mighty swing he brought it down on the
neck of a chinese boy cowering before us
the head was cut clean off and tumbled
away on the group as the body slumped
forward blood spurting
in two great gushing fountains from the
neck the officer suggested i take the
head home as a souvenir i remember
smiling proudly as i took his sword and
began killing people
why did you
you know you obviously this
bothered you why did you put this in
there i wanted to show people that the
japanese soldiers were inculcated to
commit violence
this is not a story that
was an isolated incident i mean it this
was happening throughout nine king and
they
massacred people on all the way up to
the capitol and they even held killing
contests in order to um to desensitize
the japanese soldiers from
from feeling reluctant in committing
these atrocities got a picture here of
corpses along the yangtze river
right here the big one
where did you find this picture
this picture uh that one came from
that's uh
moriasi uh
yeah that's a japanese correspondent who
took that picture that was reprinted in
several other publications
so um it's
it's really
i'm telling you that's not the most
gruesome picture there you may not want
to show
the audience some of the others that are
in my book well actually i think
we do want to show the picture so that
they can see the um
i mean not that picture on the other
side if we can pick it up on the other
side that picture right there
what's this
uh the one on the left right here oh
right
that's a number of uh heads that have
just been put out you know they they've
this was the typical scene in nanking
beheadings
sometimes they would put heads up on
posts like that picture underneath
so that people could understand what it
would be like if they've continued to
resist japan and where was this done
this was this was done in king but also
throughout i mean throughout china
actually
what was the history of why the japanese
were in china in 1937 and then king
well in
1937 the japanese found an opportunity
to provoke a war with china and it's
called the marco polo bridge incident
and
we probably don't have too much detail
to go into we don't have too much time
to go into that but um it escalated into
a full-scale war and the japanese
invaded shanghai
uh
in in the fall of
and the the
they had originally thought that the war
would take
a place only
only three months they thought that they
could conquer china in a matter of
months but when
one battle alone in one chinese city
shanghai dragged on for that long
the japanese were anxious to i think
make an example of a city they were they
were furious and frustrated and
that was the mood that the soldiers were
in as they marched from shanghai to name
king where is nan king in china
nan king is situated in a bend of the
yangtze river it is
maybe we can show a map right now
i'll find it go ahead
it's uh it's only a few miles away it
just shows the massacre
location that's right uh
shanghai would be
on the coast of china and this and then
king's further inland and um
the city is right in this in uh like
situated right at the bend of where the
the river courses um
uh you know
to the north and then turns to flow
um
uh towards the coast so when the
japanese swept towards nan king they had
all they had to do was encircle it from
three other lo three other um directions
because this the river itself formed a
natural barrier
have you been to the nan king absolutely
how many times uh actually
in the summer of 1995 i was there for uh
you know for several weeks actually just
one time and what's your personal
connection to nan king well um my my
father was born in that area and my
family actually
uh my my grandparents used to live in
nan king and they were almost separated
forever
shortly before the
the massacre itself
and when did you first can you remember
the first time you ever heard about the
rape of men yes i was a little girl
i don't remember exactly how old i was
but
i must have been in grade school at the
time and my parents were professors
at the university of illinois at urbana
were telling me about the nanjing datu
shah which is chinese for the nang king
massacre
and they said that the
killing had been so intense
in nanking that the river
the nanjing river literally red ran red
with blood for days and they
said that people were being
hacked to pieces
and at the time this was
this was very hard for me to to
visualize and i really wanted to learn
more about it so i went to the local
libraries to see if i could find
anything about it and
there wasn't a single book in english on
it i couldn't find anything
so what'd you do next oh well i think as
a child i probably just forgot about it
and i didn't really think about it for
another 20 years
the rape and king didn't intrude in my
life until
until i was married and i was living in
santa barbara and a filmmaker friend of
mine told me
that uh that he had two friends who um
who had heard that that people were uh
had had been filming a documentary on
the rape and king but that they had
problems securing funding i think for
distribution because of japanese
influence in this country and that's
what piqued my interest again and
i located the filmmakers and
and talked to them and
one of them nancy tong who
produced the documentary in the name of
the emperor told me that there was
considerable chinese activism on this
event and that if i was interested
i should contact uh you know this
particular organization which is called
the alliance for the preservation of
the truth of world war ii and as it
turns out this particular organization
was hosting a conference on the rape of
name king in december 1994 so
since i was in santa barbara and the
conference was to be held in cupertino
i just drove up
and attended
the the event now
what i wasn't prepared for was the fact
that they had put poster-sized
pictures of some of these atrocities and
i was seeing these pictures for the very
first time
and
i i was
i remember i felt sick to my stomach and
i mean i really
um i i thought at one point that i would
have to go home because i was just so
ill you know i and i resolved to do
something you know i thought
this was so bad and yet no one had still
written a book about it so i figured
that it was time
to uh
you know to take initiative who is this
woman up here
lee shoeing
lee showing
is she alive
oh yes she is
and what's the story
well
back in in 1937 she was a teenage
wife of a technician who had fled from
the city of nanking
on top of a train and she was left
behind in the city and she ended up
fighting off
three soldiers who tried to rape her
they stabbed her more than 30 times
where does she live now she lives the
name king did you talk to her yes i did
how long um i spoke to her for several
hours and i felt like a time traveler
because i saw this picture of her you
know when she was still a teenager
and
and when i met her face-to-face she was
almost 80 years old what's she look like
now
well she's still a very
she's a very feisty woman she's very
strong one of the strongest women i've
ever met
she's she's
um
well she's she has so many wrinkles now
that they've covered up the scars but
when she was younger the scars on her
face were horrible
again she was
stabbed 37 times with bayonets that's
correct
can you remember anything else about the
story where was she at the time she was
stabbed she was hiding in the
international safety zone which was a
neutral
zone organized by the foreigners of nan
king to protect them from the japanese
and we'll probably talk more about that
later but at the time a soldier had his
eye on her when when he went down into
into the basement where she was hiding
and uh he tried to rape her but she
resolved to fight to the death to
prevent from being raped so um
luckily she was bigger than he was so
that when he lunged i guess when he came
for her she she uh like ripped
his bayonet from its sheath and and she
she threw i guess her back against the
wall and she just started grappling with
him and she ended up using him
as a human shield against the two other
soldiers who were trying to stab her and
protect you know
him but she was using him as a as a
shield to prevent from getting slashed
up how did she survive
well she survived just barely
one bayonet
stabbed her right in in the stomach and
she eventually lost her baby
but she she fainted and she was almost
buried alive by her family who didn't
realize that she was still alive but
someone noticed the bubbles the blood
frothing from her mouth and they rushed
her to the hospital where
the american doctor robert wilson saved
her life
now
she's now 80 some years old when you
talk to her how did how many times did
somebody ask her about this over the
years oh um i think i think other
reporters had talked with her i'm not
really sure
you talk about your dad being born near
there what about your grandparents
well um my mother's
parents were
in nan king
in 1937
my i mean
my my grandfather actually
was was in the city as the japanese were
bombing it and uh
and there's just an incredible story of
how how they were almost separated
forever during the chaos that followed
the uh the mass evacuations what
happened after that i mean i know this i
read the story but tell us more about it
okay um
you see
when when the fighting in
shanghai um escalated it just became
clear to my grandfather that
his wife who was then a young woman in
her 20s wasn't really safe he didn't
want her to be in the city where the
japanese were bombarding hospitals and
schools and so he sent her to her home
village which was
near the city of
and
when he he went back to visit her in the
village but then when he journeyed back
to nanking he didn't realize that the
entire capital was moving inland and
that his particular unit was was just
they were leaving they were going to
leave town and and he
had to get word to my grandmother to
join him
uh in another city so that they could
leave that whole region
and
they were to meet in woohoo because i
think some of the
the railroad tracks to nan king had
already been bombed and so
as he waited for her you know she didn't
show up she waited for four days and he
didn't know that it was just taking a
long time
because
uh the trans i mean the railroads had
been bombed out and everyone was trying
to get on a sampon to get out of there
and so he waited and waited eventually
it got to be
it it
got to the point where he really had to
make a choice he would either leave the
city
and leave wuhu
and and maybe never see his wife again
or he could wait for his wife
and his daughter
and
and then
meet up with them but
miss the boat out of the region knowing
that that area would be overrun by
japanese soldiers
and
he was so desperate right when he turned
to leave he he screamed out her name
he pay just screamed it out and
in one last
it happened that she was my grandmother
was in there and she stuck her head out
and yelled back and
and it was because of that fateful cry
that they were reunited otherwise
um you know otherwise my mother would
have never been born they probably would
have never seen each other again
when did they leave china
uh they didn't leave china until shortly
before the 1949 communist revolution
so um that that would have been sometime
in the 1940s are they alive
unfortunately um both have passed away
my grandfather lived up to
be 94 years old and he passed away
in 1993 and my grandmother
died this this last summer it's very
unfortunate she didn't get to see the
publication of this book and did you
talk to both of them about the material
in this book yes actually my grandfather
because he was a poet and a journalist
and a book author he had written about
some of this in his autobiography but i
did have a chance to interview my
grandmother as well and she provided
some more details before she died and
where did you grow up i grew up in
champaign-urbana illinois
which is where my parents were
professors how long did you live there
first almost exactly 20 years i moved
there when i was
my father was offered a position when i
guess i was about one i went to school
there went to the university and and
left i think at age 21. and are they
still there yes they are
and where did you move after you left
champaign well um
i worked briefly as a reporter for the
chicago tribune and the associated press
in chicago
and then i went to the johns hopkins
university writing seminars program
where i received my master's degree
then i got married and moved out to
california where my husband was working
and where do you live now i live in
sunnyvale california which is
which is the heart of silicon valley
you say in the book that the japanese
have never apologized for this that's
correct never officially apologized
why
well i think because there's there's
really no reason for them to do so
unless they were pressured to do so
and why hasn't somebody pressured him to
do so i mean you compared a lot with
what the germans have done
well i think maybe demographics has
something to do with it i mean some of
this activism uh behind the event is
fairly new but i would say the cold war
has a large
uh role in this the silence of of of the
japanese and the the chinese and the
americans on this issue um
after the the communist revolution
neither i think the prc nor the roc
really wanted to pressure japan to pay
reparations uh and and to um apologize
because both of them needed japan as an
ally against each other they needed
japan for economic and political reasons
and
the united states also sought out japan
as
its ally as well against the forces of
communism in asia
back in 1937 how many people lived in
nanking
before the bombings before some of the
evacuations about a million people and
what was the relationship between china
and japan back then what was going on in
the world and what was their
relationship
back in 1937 oh things by that point had
been a tense i mean in the summer of
1937
uh japan had uh
um
had attacked uh shanghai
but this i mean this is a re they had
war was had already broken out but what
was the reason
well um it goes back a long way but i
the japanese had actually for hundreds
of years ambitions in china it's it's
really it's not something that um
it was not something that just started
in 1937.
it was uh it has there's a long history
of animosity here what's the reason
reason for the animosity
well
again you know we
i don't know if we have enough time to
go into this but um there had already
been uh you know war between
you know there was a there was a first
sino-japanese war
and uh there had been already um
numerous attempts by the japanese to
carve up
parts of china
they had already seized manchuria by the
1930s
what was it and and what is it about it
what was it the japanese character that
led to this kind of slaughtering i mean
what did you find in this process i
assume you've asked people about that
see it's it's very complicated actually
another historian said that trying to
peer into the japanese mind was like
trying to stare down a black hole it's
it's very
very difficult often to find out the
motives for this
i would say though that um if you're
looking at the the soldiers themselves
you'll find
that many of them had been so brutalized
uh before the massacre that um
that i think that the rape that the ma
the nang king massacre was
was an episode in which just this much
of the pent-up frustration that they had
experienced had exploded
so the japanese the japanese soldier
was um systematically um hazed for years
uh before nan king i mean he was
you have to imagine just how
how intense the the japanese military
experience really was
he had to endure
getting slapped around by
japanese
officers i mean there were accounts of
japanese soldiers being forced to wash
their underwear they they were treated
almost as sub-human within their own
army and it's often been suggested that
those who have the least power can
become the most sadistic when they do
gain
some chance to unleash the frustration
that was bottled inside how much
discussion have you had with japanese
people
about this event
i i had opera i had the opportunity to
talk to a group of japanese
students who were who are studying in
san francisco and they were absolutely
shocked to find out what happened i mean
they had been kept in the dark about
this all their lives they said that
their
their textbooks had contained only one
line on the nanking massacre which i
think was referred to as the nanjing
incident
and
i remember that when i showed them some
of the photographs i think one one woman
burst into tears
so it's clear that the me that many of
the japanese people to this day don't
really know what happened
i mean the ignorance in japan on this
event and on other atrocities is
appalling
if you if you look i mean i i talked
with a college professor
in japan
and and he said
that
when he mentioned to his students
remember these are college students
that japan had been at war with the u.s
many of these students asked him which
side won
so in other words
they're not being taught about this in
school and the ministry of education has
for decades
censored this event and others from
their textbooks i mean this has been
the subject of a 30-year lawsuit between
the japanese government
and a famous historian there inaugura
is there a chinese holocaust museum
well there actually is a rape of an king
museum in nanjing
it has the big a big number 300 000
inscribed on it
but that's about it and but i've met
people in los angeles who are interested
in building a chinese holocaust museum
uh in this country you say that the
house of representatives got into this
well actually that's no that's something
different that's the lipinski bill
no i didn't mean that they got into the
holocaust museum they got into this
whole issue of the rape that's right
william lipinski
who is the democrat from illinois has
introduced a bill in congress that calls
for the japanese to officially apologize
to its world war ii of victims and to
pay reparations
and the rape of nan king is only one
aspect of the bill he lists many other
atrocities such as you know the korean
comfort women issue
the medical experimentation that the
japanese had conducted
including vivisection without anesthesia
on american and chinese prisoners of war
um
you know the baton death march there
there are so many other instances of
wartime atrocity that are mentioned in
his bill and uh
it's i think they have more than uh 30
supporters right now in congress what
was the killing contest you mentioned it
earlier how did it work the killing
contest yes well there were two
sub-lieutenants who
wanted to see who could kill
a hundred
chinese first and the the japanese media
covered this avidly as if it was some
kind of sporting event
and
they they when they reached the you know
the hundred mark they i guess they had
lost counts they figured okay let's just
up it up let's just up this to 150.
you've got the what the actual newspaper
that's right that's right and you can
see over here the numbers 105 and 106.
what's that that that's how close they
were they were running neck to neck you
see you know one had killed
105 people another had locked off 106
heads and that was actually published in
the japanese industry that's right so
this was clearly something the japanese
people knew about at the time
who was conducting the contest oh these
two these two subs i mean who was
challenging them whose idea was it did
they do it i'm not really clear on the
details of this but um but this was not
typical this was what's happening
throughout nan king here's the picture
says and then can the japanese turn
murder into sport note the smiles on the
japanese in the background and here's
the photo right there
where do you find all these photos many
of these photos were later collected by
the name king government
for their war crimes
tribunals against the japanese after the
war
but sometimes the japanese soldiers
themselves took these pictures
when i talked with one of the survivors
he remembers that as he stood uh you
know on the edge of this pit watching
all the japanese lop off heads and throw
them in a you know to the side and what
you know one person was keeping count
keeping score and the other one was uh
laughing and taking photographs you know
there's an incredible story about how
this one album of 16 photographs
eventually made its way from photoshop
to uh to like a to a toilet you know to
uh and it was hidden for years until it
finally ended up in an archives
a couple of these pictures in here are
rough to look at
i've showed them yet are you
was it a tough decision to put them in
the book
it was it was i was very concerned that
some of these pictures
would result in the book being banned
from
school libraries but um i had numerous
discussions with this with you know the
people at harpercollins and with
with other historians and friends and
some people
insisted that you know i put them in
anyway uncensored because this was
history this was the truth what's this
photo over here
um that's the photo of a woman
who a rape victim who is being forced to
pose next to a japanese soldier naked
they found these photos in the wallets
of some of the japanese soldiers you
know they took them
and sometimes the the people in the
local photo mat would
would make copies because they knew how
important they were on the other page at
the top which that's what's that photo i
still have problems looking at it that's
a woman who's been impaled after
she's been raped right down here
and where did you find this
this again came came from china
and
it was it's it's it came from the
chinese archives and the photo above it
um that's a picture of a woman who's
been gang-raped
and she as you could see she's been tied
to the chair so that she could be raped
um
whenever the soldiers were in the mood
for it and
again i mean i have a hard time even
looking at these pictures even now
what's the purpose of putting them in
the book then what has you decided what
in the end what what was the how the
conversation like between you and the
publisher
well you know
there were people in the publishing
house who had problems looking at the
pictures um
in the end we decided that it was just
it was important for people to see what
they were capable of doing and um it was
a tough decision i
um
and i know that i might i may well catch
a lot of criticism for it but i don't
think that people will realize just how
brutal the japanese were until they see
these pictures
if i were a japanese sitting here and
saw these i would say things like what's
your proof that this actually is
something that was caused by a japanese
soldier
well all i can say is that there are
thousands of pages of primary
uh source documents on this event four
different languages that's that pretty
much describe with words these very
pictures and um and many of these
pictures they're not they're not they
don't didn't all come from japan and
china many of them
can be found in the united states in the
missionary uh collections
let me show you this picture right here
and ask you to tell me what it is
the one to the right the one up top
the bayonet the bayonetting well
these are pictures of the japanese
bayonetting
victims and and they're doing it for
practice they're using live prisoners as
practice
and um
and
as you can see um
this the gentleman the the chinese who's
been blindfolded i mean he's he's been
stabbed repeatedly
and this is happening even after he's
dead you say that's just practice it's
just practice below that this photograph
this is a photograph of
several japan several chinese victims
being buried alive as japanese soldiers
watch
and you also tell a story in there where
they would bury
some chinese
victims up to their heads and then have
german shepherds or tear them apart
tear them apart did you have any
pictures of that no
thank god how did you find that out um
well that that was that came out of our
you know archival documents and also
came out of descriptions which i found
in china i'm telling you
literally i had so many facts on these
atrocities i i had i had to use a
computer database for them in order to
keep keep them you know in order i mean
i i we had that much evidence on it if
we had when did you start writing this
book or when did you start compiling all
the images i started compiling the
information
probably in january or february 1995.
and i noticed that uh as late as
august almost the end of august you had
something quoted in here from the japan
times and this book came out in december
how did you get it how would you were
able to publish it that close well you
see the we we really had to publish this
right at the last minute because all of
this activism it's ongoing and and um we
really were working right down to the
last minute on this book it was a very
tight schedule and why is you mean
you're afraid you're going to lose the
opportunity if you didn't get it
published right away it's it's it's a
long story i mean harper collins itself
as you know has has been through some
difficulty and you know they eventually
canceled more than 100 book contracts
and and you know there were some delays
in the process but um but that was okay
because that gave me the opportunity to
put in some other information that
should have gone in the book
um you know i i never thought for
instance that i would ended up finding
the family of john robbe who is the nazi
hero of nan king and
you know i i located the diaries and
located the family halfway through the
project so i mean this was an ongoing
process and you talked to his daughter
uh his granddaughter that's right ursula
reinhardt i mean that i've i've
tracked down the family when i think the
book was almost finished so
so yes revisions were made up to the
last minute and who is john robbie john
robbie was the head of the nazi party in
nanking but he was also
the head of the international safety
zone committee in nanking which is that
group of about 20 foreigners who decided
to create in name king a two and a half
square
mile
area for the refugees during the
massacre
they told the japanese that this area
was off limits to them and they had to
feed these refugees and protect them
from the japanese you have a letter in
here dated 8th june 1938 and it's dear
sure signed by john robbie that letter
went to hitler
why
well he was hoping to stop the
atrocities by informing the highest
levels of german government about the
nanking massacre he
may he may have been a little naive but
he really thought that
perhaps the germans would
pressure the japanese to stop the
killing so what he did was in 1938 when
he went back to berlin he brought with
him a copy of john mcgee's film of the
massacre and john mcgee was was the uh
was the episcopalian minister who took
uh footage of
of uh some of the atrocities uh actually
he's the gentleman right right on the
other page actually which one uh the the
the picture that's a little lower on the
page which one to the right
this gentleman okay fine we'll get it
here so people can see what he looks
like
yeah he shot scenes from the nan king
hospital
and um
it was this film that um was reproduced
and and you know in shanghai it was
smuggled out in inking and this
and they made several copies john robbie
took one of these copies he also kept
diaries of the mask or he brought those
along with him to to berlin and he he
sent a copy of the film to hitler and he
and he was hoping to make some kind of
i guess change in german policy towards
japan but the net result
of the uh of sending the film was was a
visit from the gestapo
and uh
they came to his home arrested him
interrogated him
uh for for uh hours
and uh eventually they
they forced him to promise them that he
would never
speak about the atrocities again
where is that film
that's a good question we are trying to
well the john mcgee's film is available
in the united states i mean several
copies of were made so they're in
different archives and different homes
but john mcgee
sorry john robbie's copy
we don't know where it is because people
have searched the german archives and
they can't find it so to this day
they're not sure if hitler has really
seen it but the family's convinced that
he did if you saw the john mcgee film
what would you see do you see the
atrocities
you would see people being led away
by the japanese soldiers you have to
remember he couldn't just you know stick
the camera up you know right
in front of their faces this had to be
done secretly so you could see
some footage
that
is filmed through like maybe a crack in
the door or a crack in the window and
you would see crowds of chinese being
taken away and the most gripping images
come from the hospital where there were
victims who had
who had escaped
being burned alive people who had been
slashed with bayonets
there's one picture where one woman's
head is just about to fall off it's it's
really very grotesque
azuma shiro or shiro ozuma depending on
how you pronounce it
is who
shirazuma is a japanese veteran of the
rape of name king
and he's still in in
he's still alive and he's in japan right
now and you corresponded with him that's
correct
how did that work how did you find him
well i had to track him down and
i think a journalist
ian baruma actually was the one who gave
me his address
and i wrote a letter to him i had it
translated into japanese
and um and he responded
almost immediately and i had uh the
letter translated back into english he
sent me a copy of his diaries
and
he also answered every question that i
had posed to him see i was trying to
understand the the the state of mind
that he was in at the time what did you
learn from him what i learned was that
the japanese soldier
really had to see the chinese as
subhuman before they could kill them i
mean he he depicted the the chinese in
his diary as
you know as like animals or as insects
right above that uh in the book
you can put this into context
a veteran officer named taminga now
tamina
tamanaga shozo recalled vividly his own
transformation from innocent youth to
killing machine
and i want to read
what you have and where did you find
that by the way um that was in a
secondary source i think it came from a
book
he scooped water from a bucket with a
dipper then poured it over both sides of
the blade swishing off the water he
raised his sword in a long arc standing
behind the prisoner tanaka steadied
himself legs spread apart and cut off
the man's head with a shout yo
the head flew more than a meter away
blood spurted up in two fountains from
the body and sprayed into the hole the
scene was so appalling that i felt i
couldn't breathe
if you were japanese what would you want
your own people to do about this if they
didn't know about it
well
i guess it would depend on the
individual but
i i don't know what they would think but
i think that
i personally think that they have a
moral responsibility to come to grips
with this japan as a nation cannot move
forward until they
until they meet this squarely in the
face well even according to your
testimony they don't even know about it
some of them don't know about it but
there are those who do and um
i remember talking to some
some japanese who when they hear it
they'll often just immediately deny it
they don't want to believe it
so
it's very hard it's very hard to know
exactly how they're going to react even
when these facts are are thrust into
their face will your book be published
in japan uh
i'm not really optimistic that it will
be but
perhaps some kind of small radical
publisher will take a risk
and and put it out
from what you know what would happen if
it were
if books were
tried to be sold over in japan i don't
know but i'll tell you that
shiro zuma who's come out
to apologize for the
for his role in the massacre he's faced
countless death threats and um many of
the journalists who've written about
this in japan
um have either been ostracized or i mean
when you see them photograph they have
sunglasses on because you know they've
they've
run into these these kinds of threats
too
don't forget the the japanese some
japanese right winger shot i think the
the the mayor of nagasaki in the back
simply because he he said that he
thought harahito had some responsibility
for the war so in 1989 that's right
so um
we have a country that is living denial
and
i'll be honest with you i i am
completely appalled that more people
don't know about this atrocity because
if you look i mean 300 000 people died
in nking and
300 000 people might not seem like a
huge number
until you place it in the context of
world war ii history 300 000 deaths
is greater than
the deaths from hiroshima and nagasaki
combined
it's also greater than the combined
civilian
deaths of several european countries for
the entire duration of world war ii so
in other words if you add up
the number of civilians who died in
england france
and belgium
that still
would not be as many people
who died in nanking which is one chinese
city in six to eight weeks
in the end more than 19 million chinese
people
perished they they
19 million people were killed
what do you want to do with this
well
i want the whole world to know what
happened i want the entire world
to know the truth and how far are you
willing to take it
well i think i've i've
just writing the book is is the
was the biggest step really for me
i think i've done my part in
in just just laying down the facts for
people to read
and
also in the book you have some americans
one in particular is robert wilson who
was he
robert wilson is uh
was the missionary doctor
and he was the only surgeon in nan king
during the um the great massacre
and what role did he play
well he was the person who ended up
having to stitch up the
the survivors who came
you know straggling into the hospital
from bayonet
wounds or burn wounds and
he was working night and day it's it's
it's incredible what he was able to do
under this condition what was the zone
the international safety zone
it was two and a half square miles in
the middle of the city
um which the the foreigners had uh
marked off with red crass flags
and um
and it was it was an area that they
claimed that the japanese were not
permitted to enter
and they tried to
you know they they just harbored the
chinese there
thousands of chinese were pouring into
the zone every day
uh many with only their clothes on their
backs and just begging for a place to
sit down so that they could be safe from
the from the japanese and how many
people were inside that zone um
hundreds of thousands one actually said
three hundred thousand one one of the
zone members said three hundred thousand
were in the zone and you tell a story
about how chinese soldiers would come in
yes
and then the japanese would come in and
how did they find them when they were
they took off their uniforms and put on
civilian clothes what was the technique
they used to find them well what they
did was they searched
their their hands to see if they had any
calluses from
handling guns they also even searched
their backs to see if there were any
backpack marks
even their feet for signs of marching
and that way they were able to find out
who had been a former chinese soldier
and they systematically marched them out
and shot them
were there was there a trial of any kind
after all that war was over there were
well the biggest one was the tokyo war
crimes trial or the in itself the formal
name is the international military
tribunal for the far east
and um that was held in japan and it
resulted in some of the class a war
criminals uh
being hanged
by the end of it was that everything
that happened in world war ii happened
at this trial i mean it would cover
everything yes it was it was covering
they were trying to cover everything but
they also had a local trial too for
name king there was a name king tribunal
as well
and how long did that go on
um
it went on for several months it was
mainly
these were held immediately after the
war and that was held in then king yes
of course the the international tribunal
for the far east lasted
considerably longer i mean went on for
years how much publicity was there for
this event either in japan or in in
kenya although there was considerable
publicity for the tokyo war crimes trial
i it was
i think was the longest war crimes trial
in history and they had you know
hundreds of reporters there
in in king it was well publicized i'm
sure throughout china
you tell a story in the beginning of the
book about
commodore matthew perry
and how the americans opened up
japan to the outside world how'd that
work
oh um well what
what perry decided to do when the
japanese ignored
requests from the american government to
open up their ports trade he he marched
up into
he he studied japanese history carefully
and then he decided that the best way to
to deal with them was to shock them into
submission and so he uh he um kind of
just came
right he just went right up
with you know to the to one of the ports
and he strode into the capitol with uh
with with some very aggressive looking
men and and it just terrified the
japanese at the time i mean this was
their the first time they had ever even
seen steam power
uh one historian said it would be
you know to really understand the
pressure the japanese were under it
would be like
an announcement maybe on cnn
that
that we have some weird looking aircraft
headed
towards earth that that was how shocked
they were at the time and this was in
july of 1853 yes was that the first time
japan had ever
seen an american
probably the first time many of them had
ever seen an american what happened to
the country after that well then they
decided to modernize and they they they
decided that they would they would
appease the barbarians but they would
they would try to learn from them
because it was obvious that they were
lagging
uh in in technology they had to learn to
to build up their military what happened
next to the country well the country did
precisely that and um there was the
meiji restoration and the entire country
became very nationalistic and
in the end they they built up a very
strong
military and and uh
and they began to get some of the
respect that they had craved actually
from the west
does the the rape of nankang or the
massacre at nankang have any impact on
the relationship today between china and
japan you ever did you talk to folks
about that when you went over there well
it's actually very interesting that you
asked me that because
um
the many of the prc officials that i've
met they're very they're sympathetic to
uh the history of the rape and king i
mean many of them may have had relatives
who died
during the sino-japanese war but at the
same time i think they are reluctant to
endanger
their their trade relations with japan
and also
um the political and diplomatic
relations so
the prc has actually as i think i may
have mentioned before has expelled
uh activists who have tried to promote
this event actually promote the history
of the rape and nanking in the back of
your book in the epilogue you say
there's a number of lessons for all this
but this is one i wanted to ask you
about another lesson to be gleaned from
nan king is the role of power
in genocide those who have studied the
patterns of large-scale killings
throughout history have noted that the
sheer concentration of power in
government is lethal that only a sense
of absolute unchecked power can make
atrocities like the rape of nanking
possible what would you say then about
today's chinese concentration of power
in that government well i think it's a
dangerous situation because we still i
mean the prc to this day it's still a
totalitarian
regime
and
it's it's
you know if you have these kinds of
conditions in place an atrocity like the
rape and can happen again what did they
think when you went to china in 1995 did
the officials know what you were doing
there
in 1995
i know they didn't and actually
i was a little concerned when i went
back because i had just written the book
the thread of the silkworm which is an
unauthorized biography of the father of
the red chinese missile program so i you
know and i knew that plenty of people
had been kicked out of china for
promoting the history of the rape and
inking so i figured that there was a
good chance that i myself would be
interrogated and expelled from the
country did they know who you were
not the people named kingdom all they
knew was that i was a scholar who was
out there seeking information
and you said you're married yes your
children not yet and what does your
husband do he's an electrical engineer
and he works in silicon valley and he's
been incredibly supportive of this
project and supportive of my career and
you said that you live in sunnyvale
which is right in silicon that's correct
and it seemed like there was somebody in
in this book that is living in sunnyvale
was it somebody that would have been so
it so turned out that there was a
paramedic
uh
you know
in in king who now lives in sunnyvale i
mean
this is somebody who when he was
uh living in nanking back in 1937 i mean
he was he was a little boy and uh but he
had volunteered to help the uh the
chinese army he was working as a
paramedic at the time
sure coincidence
in the book you talk about in the
beginning of the rape of nan king a
an incident that 57 000 people were
killed
oh yes that must be the the moofal
mountain massacre that's correct and
what was that
well what they had done was they
they had kept these tens of thousands of
civilians
in in these camps and then eventually
after keeping them
dehydrated and starved
they just went out and just
just started machine gunning them
killing them was that the most that ever
died at one time i think it may have
been
what's your sense of what would lead a
human being to do this kind of thing
i think
that i think that people are much more
capable of committing these atrocities
than
we would think and i think that if
you're conditioned
to believe that what you're doing is the
right thing if somehow
if the act of murder becomes like a holy
one then it would it would be uh easy i
think to to convince people that not
only what you're doing is is wrong but
that it is it's sanctioned by god and
that it is
it's it's the only right thing you can
do
have you talked at all about what
happened in rwanda
um
they're actually
in this book it mentions rwanda just
briefly but i i would say when i was
looking at the news accounts
you know i i felt like i was reviewing
my old archival documents again it was
that some of the similarities were
haunting stories about
women who had been raped by soldiers and
now they're going to carry an enemy
soldier's baby and
and
these these dilemmas that were so
painful to me when reading them because
you know i kept seeing the same story
over and over again you tell a story in
here i think a woman to this day won't
give
her real name or what was it was raped
and i can't remember exactly what it was
but you alluded to it then what was that
that some of the rapes that happened
eventually children were born you see
yes some some there were many half
japanese half chinese children born as a
result of this rape and
one of the missionaries at the time
louis smith said that you know there
were thousands of these children
being smothered to death or drowned
because very few women really wanted i
mean they couldn't love these children
and but
you have to understand that they had it
must have been a terrible choice for
these women to make i mean
killing your own baby or raising a child
that you could never love and i'm sure a
lot of women couldn't make that choice
so at the same time there were thousands
of women also
committing suicide in the city i mean
there were uncounted women
throwing themselves into the youngster
river to drown how interested have you
found
americans in this story
i am surprised the response i mean it's
overwhelming it seems to me that almost
everyone i've talked with is interested
and they're shocked they don't know
about this why don't we know about it in
the united states
well
i i i sometimes wonder if it's maybe
demographics
um
you know it's
it's it's really stunning to me that i i
really don't know the answer to that
question i mean i hope it's simply it
was just lack of interest maybe there
weren't enough
chinese and japanese experts
uh
you know immediately after the war
but you know the united states
government itself was engaged in a a
you know in the conspiracy with with
the japanese to cover up some of their
own
uh you know some of their own dealings
so there are many political reasons why
something like this wouldn't be told
what was that moment in here that you
talked about when fdr
had uh that's correct how much 30
seconds of film or 30 minutes of film
take maybe 30 feet of film 30 feet of
film right see um yes the
well as you know the japanese had bombed
the uss panay
and some americans had died as a result
of this bombing and uh the japanese
later on tried to excuse the the bombing
by saying well it was a cloudy day or we
couldn't really see clearly that this
was an american ship but it wasn't by
the way it was a gun boat and it was
bombed on december 12th
yes yes right right the japanese had
entered the city and um
but you know there were two newsreel men
aboard and one of them uh well both of
them took footage of the japanese
swooping down almost to deck level to
shoot at the the passengers and it's
clear from anyone who looks at the
footage that the japanese could see the
flags that were painted on the deck or
or flying overhead and
the president
specifically requested that this footage
be removed before it was shown in
american theaters why
well we could only speculate on the
reasons why
it's probably because they didn't want
to jeopardize any kind of settlement
that they wanted to make with japan
we're out of time this is our
guest book cover book jacket the rape of
nan king
and our guest has been iris chang thank
you very much thank you
the redesigned booknotes website now
features over which is one of the rooms
of the miami-dade community college for
irish chang
against what was then china's capital
city nan king in the late 1930s
two decades passed iris graduated from
the university of illinois and went on
to earn a master's degree at johns
hopkins
she married her college sweetheart and
published a biography on the scientists
who developed china's missile program
then in 1994 iris attended a conference
in northern california on japanese war
atrocities and saw poster sized photos
of nanking victims
mutilated and tortured bodies rape
victims forced into pornographic poses
faces contorted into unforgettable
expressions of terror and shame
iris finally saw with her own eyes what
her parents had told her about
and she found herself in a panic a panic
born in the fear that the massacre would
forever be just a footnote in history or
even worse just as some would have us
believe that the holocaust against jews
never happened in nazi germany that some
japanese politicians continued to deny
the carnage that took place in nanking
fortunately
irish chang's book the rape of nan king
the forgotten holocaust of world war ii
is making that denial hard to fathom
the massacre at nanking is not just a
footnote anymore the book followed two
years of research iris iris interviewed
survivors and japanese army veterans she
read diaries of american missionaries
and other foreigners in nanking at the
time and she read newspaper and military
accounts
the work was so painful
that iris lost a lot of her hair and a
lot of her weight
the rape of nanking tells the story of a
massacre where as many as 350 000 men
women and children were slaughtered in a
six to eight week period
more lives were lost in nking than
during the atomic bombings of nagasaki
and hiroshima combined
but the rape of nan king does more does
a lot more than simply narrate details
of barbarism and tragedy
the book looks at the militaristic
culture that allowed for a total
disregard of human life
and it tells the story of the second
rape
how the cold war led to a concerted
effort by the west and even china to
stifle discussion of what had happened
in ant king and the rest of the country
during the japanese invasion
since the book's publication iris has
had a grueling schedule of readings
interviews and speaking engagements
what keeps her going
as she told a newspaper reported this
past summer
i am giving voice to hundreds of
thousands of people who perished in 1937
and who are not as lucky as me had i
been born at the wrong time the wrong
place the wrong country i could have
easily been one of the victims i could
have one i could have been one of the
nameless bodies heaped in some nameless
pile of corpses in those photos and i
would not want to be forgotten
i do this for them
and she did it for us
thank you iris
greetings
it's a great honor to be here
and i want to thank all of you
for
coming here to learn about a side of
world war ii history that some of you
may be hearing about for the first time
i plan to speak for about half an hour
i'm going to leave 15 minutes for
questions and and
that i'd be glad to answer
um when we all think of world war ii
i think that we tend not to think of the
asian side
of of the um the
war at the time
you know we we tend to think of
uh the
european holocaust d-day if we do think
of the the asian theater at all we tend
to visualize the mushroom clouds over
hiroshima and nagasaki
so i think that many americans are truly
not aware of the full story of the
pacific side to world war ii and by this
i mean the atrocities committed by the
japanese armies against millions
of chinese people
southeast asians koreans filipinos and
even our own american citizens
now during world war ii
japan's invasion of china
launched an eight-year war which
ultimately killed an estimated
19 million to 35 million chinese people
and during this time the japanese
military also lured purchased or
kidnapped hundreds of thousands of women
for sexual slavery for their imperial
army women who were subjected to some of
the most horrifying experiences
inflicted upon military prostitutes in
history what i plan to do this morning
is use the rape of nanking the subject
of my new book as just one example to
illustrate what the japanese did in many
of the regions that they conquered
i'll also show some of the glaring scars
that were left behind
which persist to this very day
about 61 years ago
in december of 1937
the japanese imperial army invaded the
city of nan king which was then the seat
of the nationalist government in china
as well as the capital of mainland china
and within a six to eight week period
the japanese army
not only looted and burned this
defenseless city
but systematically raped tortured and
murdered
some three hundred thousand chinese
civilians
it's very hard i think for all of us
to conceptualize
300 000 deaths until we put this number
in the context of world history
more people would die from the rape of
man king then from the atomic blasts at
hiroshima and nagasaki combined
in fact the death toll of nan king just
one chinese city alone
during six to eight weeks far exceeded
the total civilian casualty count of
three european countries combined for
all of world war ii
england france and belgium
so
it's important to realize that nan king
is already one of the greatest
atrocities of world history and yet it
is just one small fraction of the
atrocities that were perpetrated
across asia and of course in china by
the japanese armies which had killed
perhaps as many as 35 million chinese
people
but numbers don't tell the full story of
the rape of name king
you really can't measure
the degree of torture
and suffering that was inflicted upon
the civilians in that city
there were stories of of women who were
nailed to walls and impaled after being
raped
or nailed to boards and run over by army
tanks
there were stories of people being
hanged by their tongues on iron hooks
or buried waste down in the soil so they
could be ripped apart by german
shepherds
even small children weren't spared the
carnage at nan king
babies were tossed in the air
and bayoneted on the way down
or thrown alive into vats of boiling
water
indeed the orgy of violence would prove
to be so brutal in the city that even
the nazi party members in nanking were
shocked at the spectacle
now the rape of nan king
was not what many japanese revisionists
claim today
a massacre that was perpetrated in the
heat of battle in which some innocent
civilians got caught in the crossfire
this was a cold and systematic massacre
that was perpetrated against thousands
of chinese civilians
and chinese unarmed pows who had already
thrown away their weapons and
surrendered after the city fell
the japanese military had issued a kill
all captives order at the time which
seems to have come as a directive from
some of the highest levels of military
power
and the japanese soldiers carried out
this order
systematically
and within the first few days the
massacre the army rounded up tens of
thousands of men
and
herded them into warehouses and then led
them out to remote areas of the city
after the men had permitted their hands
to be tied behind their backs
and across the city the army machine
gunned tens of thousands of chinese men
or buried them alive or used them for a
bayonet practice
or decapitation contests or
thousands of men were simply sprayed
with gasoline and set on fire
now most of these executions were
efficient but there were men who died
under the most slow sadistic and
excruciatingly painful circumstances
when japanese soldiers turned murder
into sport
there were cases of chinese men
who were skinned alive
crucified pricked to death by needles
and even cannibalized
and
so many men
were killed during those first few days
of massacre that the japanese army
literally had problems disposing of all
the corpses burial of course was one
method
but
a japanese general was soon complaining
in his diary that they had run out of
ditches large enough to hold
seven or eight thousand corpses at a
time
a cremation was another method but the
japanese army soon ran out of gasoline
so they were left with mountains of uh
charred flesh
in the end
many bodies thousands of bodies were
simply dumped into the yangtze river the
waters of which
were filled with bloated corpses and ran
red with blood for days
after killing most of the men in the
city in this fashion
the japanese army then turned their
attention on the chinese women
making the rape of nang king the single
greatest mass rape of world history up
to that moment
it is now the second worst mass rape of
world history second only to the
wholesale violation of bengali women by
pakistani soldiers in the 1970s after a
failed rebellion
in the city of nanking
no woman was safe
japanese soldiers
raped great-grandmothers over the ages
of 80
along with children under the ages of
eight
often victims were raped in broad
daylight in front of hundreds of
pedestrians often in the middle of
streets
and
the army did more than just rape women
but and girls but often mutilated them
horribly with tree branches
bayonets swords golf sticks and even lit
firecrackers
there were even stories of soldiers who
sliced open small children to ravish
them more effectively
and even stories of pregnant women who
were gang-raped before
the fetuses were torn out of their
bellies as trophies
and these aren't even some of the worst
stories
chinese sons were sometimes even forced
to rape their own mothers
or
fathers their own daughters or brothers
their own sisters as other family
members watched
those who refused were usually killed on
the spot
in the end
the japanese raped more than 20 000
women and girls the nan king and some
estimate that the figure is probably as
high as 80 000 women and girls
but i think the full effects of the rape
can't be measured on a tally sheet of
statistics
because many of the women who survived
weeks of gang rape found themselves
pregnant afterwards and therefore face
the choice of committing infanticide or
rearing half japanese children that they
could never love
and i think that many chinese women
simply could not make that choice nor
could they live with the trauma of what
they had endured
and for months after the great rape of
nanking
it was observed that countless numbers
of women in the city were simply taking
their own lives by fleeing themselves
into the youngster river
but the rape of nan king did more than
destroy the lives of individual women in
the city
it also appears to have resulted in an
underground system of military
prostitution which destroyed the lives
of hundreds of thousands of women
across asia
the rape of nan king had created a huge
public outcry among western nations at
the time and this was front page news in
the new york times and many other
western papers
and it's believed that it caused such
bad press for the japanese government
that the government tried to control the
libido of the japanese soldiers by
creating their own prostitution ring
which we now know as the comfort women's
system or the korean comfort women's
system
an estimated 200 000 women most of them
korean women but many also from other
asian countries some of whom were also
caucasian such as dutch women were
forced to serve in what the japanese
government called facilities of sexual
comfort to stop troops from raping women
in regions that they controlled in china
the japanese established their first
comfort station between nanking and
shanghai shortly after the nanking
massacre in 1938
and many of these comfort women
were only you know teenagers or even
children when they were captured
and they were often attacked by as many
as 20 30 or 50 men a night every night
for years during the war and untold
numbers of these women whom the japanese
army called public toilets took their
own lives when they learned their
destiny
and and countless others died from
outright
murder or disease
indeed only one in four comfort women
survived the experience
and if
many of you are learning about this for
the first time it is because the first
comfort women did not step forward to
tell their stories until the early 90s
and
and their stories were so horrific
that when one comfort woman went to the
justice department
to
disclose what had happened to her
many of the men in the audience most of
them
hardened nazi war criminal hunters
found themselves in tears i don't think
there was a dry eye in the audience
now decades later
the japanese government tried to insist
that these brawls were run by private
entrepreneurs and not the wartime
government
but just a few years ago a japanese
professor by the name of doctor
yoshiyaka ushiaki yoshima
cho university
found undeniable evidence in the
japanese government archives that the
entire system was indeed authorized by
officials of the japanese high command
and this man this professor found
documents bearing the stamps and seals
of some of the most powerful japanese
members in government at the time
so that does make the wartime government
responsible
and
you know i can't possibly mention all
the atrocities that were committed by
the japanese armies throughout china or
even just in the city of nanking
because of time limitations but i will
mention however
a little about the joseph mengele-like
medical experimentation that was
inflicted upon name king civilians after
the massacre and elsewhere in china such
as the notorious unit 731 laboratory in
manchuria
in the city of nanking the japanese
operated a secret medical lab code named
ei 1644
in which
they fed human guinea pigs
with cyanide snake poison germs and
lethal gases
japanese doctors working at the secret
lab killed about 10 people weekly in
this manner and incinerated the bodies
but in unit 731 which was not in nanking
but in manchuria the japanese doctors
killed even more people performing
horrendous experiments and even
vivisection without anesthesia on both
american and chinese prisoners and again
if some of you are hearing about this
for the first time it is because
a lot of this was covered up actually by
our own government
after the war
the u.s government actually exonerated
the japanese doctors responsible for
committing these atrocities in exchange
for their medical data which was often
detained at the expense of american pows
and these japanese doctors went back to
japan where they then assumed powerful
positions
in government academia and business
some even became founders and executives
at the green cross blood processing
plant which is now defunct a corporation
which was
caught a few years ago selling hiv
tainted blood to japanese hemophiliac
patients
so the victims of this medical
experimentation involve not only
american and chinese victims but
japanese victims as well who are simply
not informed
of the backgrounds of some of the
leading members of the japanese medical
establishment
in sum when you look back on all of
these atrocities you would think
that with such a record that the
japanese government would have shown
proper remorse a long time ago for the
genocide that was perpetrated across
asia
but that's not the situation at all to
this very day
the japanese government takes very
little responsibility for these
atrocities even though the wartime
government had given the orders to
commit them
and there have even been politicians in
japan who have gone on the record in the
last few years to deny that any of these
atrocities happened at all this is why i
believe that the story of the rape of
nan king and the story of other
atrocities is really the story of two
rapes the first rape happened 60 years
ago
but the second rape is ongoing and it is
the rape of history and the rape of
justice
over the last 60 years japan has almost
completely escaped the moral and
financial responsibility that their
counterparts in germany had to face over
and over again
let's just give out a few examples
in the realm of
apologies we all know that germany has
made several profuse apologies to their
wartime victims
but the japanese government has yet to
deliver one sincere apology directly to
the survivors of the nanking massacre or
to their families
and the ex
some of the apologies that they claim to
have made to the wartime victims in
general have often avoided the word use
of the words apologies in general
preferring words like remorse
or
regret and is not really
deemed as sincere by many of the victims
of the japanese across asia now
as
many of you who have been following the
news may know a few weeks ago
japan has made a written apology
to
the south korean government
and a similar apology was promised to
the chinese government and we'll see
what will happen
uh in just about a week uh when zhang
jiaming visits tokyo because that's when
the prom the apology is supposedly going
to be delivered
now in the realm of war restitution the
differences between how the two
countries have dealt with their wartime
past loom large
the germans have paid the equivalent of
about 60 billion u.s dollars
in war reparations to their victims and
will continue to pay several more
billion by the year 2005
but the japanese government has paid
close to nothing and certainly not one
penny in reparations to the victims of
nan king
what's even more disturbing i think is
how the subject of world war ii is
taught in schools in both countries
the germans have required by law the
teaching of the history of the jewish
holocaust in their schools
and any teacher who refuses to
participate or neglects to teach this
history is simply breaking the law
but the japanese government far from
mandating the study of their world were
to aggression has through the ministry
of education openly impeded the efforts
of textbook authors to do so in that
country and have even censored
whitewashed or distorted details of the
nanking atrocities and other work time
crimes from school textbooks despite a
three-decade-long lawsuit waged against
the ministry of education by textbook
author and historian anaga saburo
to such an extent
that um
many people who have gone through the
japanese school system
uh are not even quite aware of what
exactly happened during world war ii in
fact
i had the opportunity to
talk with a japanese college professor
who told me that
many students in his class had actually
approached him with a question of
we know that
that japan and the us had been at war
during you know the second world war but
which side won
so
i think that whatever is being done
in terms of public education in japan is
simply not adequate
but
there's also a revisionist movement in
japan underway in in germany when you
look at germany they've simply made it
illegal in their country to openly deny
the existence of the holocaust
but in japan legions of professors
filmmakers journalists and even leading
members of government have openly
proclaimed that the rape of nanking and
other war atrocities never happened at
all or were minor incidents much
overblown
there is a vocal minority of activists
and scholars in japan who openly refute
this view and they have worked hard to
raise awareness of japan's wartime past
in that country and have published books
on the subject and as well as brought
litigation against the government
on behalf of the victims but some of
these
individuals have faced ostracism death
threats and even assassination attempts
from members of the ultra-nationalist
fanatics
and factions in
japan
for example just a few years ago
the mayor of nagasaki was shot in the
chest
merely for stating his belief publicly
that emperor harajito bore some
responsibility for world war ii
and while
nazi war criminals are vilified in
germany and seen as the source of great
national shame japanese class a war
criminals are worshipped as deities in
the yasukuni shrine in tokyo
a practice which is not only morally
reprehensible but indeed the source of
tremendous anguish
to wartime victims across asia
and i think it's something that would
never be tolerated if it's parallel were
practiced in europe the worship of these
men in the yasakuni shrine is the moral
and political equivalent of moving
statues of hitler's cronies
and leading wartime criminals
into the biggest cathedral of berlin and
honoring these men as gods
at this point the question inevitably
arises which is how did all of this
happen i mean why
do differences in post-war behavior loom
so large between germany and japan
and the answer i believe really lies in
the cold war
after 1949
neither chinese government neither the
people's republic of china
nor the republic of china based in
taiwan
wanted to push japan for apologies or
reparations or to broadcast news of
these atrocities worldwide because both
governments were competing for japan's
diplomatic and political recognition
the united states government also failed
to pursue the issue because it saw japan
as potentially a stable base that they
could build up to counter the forces of
communism in the soviet union and in
asia so cold war concerns in
the united states the people's republic
of china and the republic of china and
taiwan
really overrode the need to press for
justice for the victims
and as a result
many of the worst wartime criminals in
japan escaped prosecution and punishment
entirely
unlike the nazi leaders of germany who
were mostly imprisoned executed or at
the very least
forced to live out the rest of their
days as fugitives from the law
the entire japanese royal family
including emperor harahito was
exonerated under the terms of the
surrender and was held exempt from
having to face prosecution or even to
testify as witnesses during the
international military tribunal of the
far east often known as the asian
equivalent of the nuremberg trials
moreover the entire japanese wartime
bureaucracy remained intact
so that those who had plunged the
country into war in the first place
were permitted thanks to american
leniency to stay in power after the war
therefore many of those officials
were left in a position to control
what was taught about world war ii in
japanese schools or what would filter
through the media to the japanese people
and even today the bitter legacy of
japan's world war ii past
and persistent refusals in that country
to admit wrongdoing
still haunts the island a nation and her
neighbors
especially during a time of financial
crisis when the need for reconciliation
is more important than ever
a revisionist movement still thrives in
japan to deny all wartime wrongdoing and
this only exacerbates the old wounds and
tensions between japan and her neighbors
let me give you just a few examples of
this revisionist movement
for
instance in may of this year a major
japanese studio released the movie pride
an instant in a lifetime which not only
depicts the japanese wartime leader tojo
as a hero and a martyr but also implies
as well that the rape of nan king never
happened at all
this movie became the top grossing film
in japan for the year
but when another movie called nancy 1937
which was produced outside of japan but
shown within japanese theaters this
summer
right-wing ultra-nationalist extremists
not only issued death threats to at
least one theater owner's family but
slashed up his screens with a knife
indeed
the police had to be called to protect
many of the theater goers
as as right-wingers demonstrated outside
meanwhile in june of this year
six japanese revisionist academics held
a conference in tokyo to deny the entire
existence of the nan king massacre
some even insisted that it was the
chinese who did all the looting raping
and murdering in the city and that it
was the chinese who had quote
unilaterally massacred all of the
japanese up to that point even though
they never explained what the japanese
army was doing in china in the first
place
and that civic life in nanking actually
improved by leaps and bounds once the
friendly soothing japanese soldiers
arrived in the city
unfortunately a mountain of evidence on
the nanking massacre
which includes thousands of pages of
primary source documents in four
different languages english
german chinese japanese that were
generated during the event as it
happened all of this evidence has not
deterred extremists in japan from
dismissing it all as propaganda or as
forgeries and so in this way the spin
strategies of these revisionists are
really no different from that of
holocaust deniers or armenian genocide
deniers in turkey the latter of which as
in japan include powerful members of
turkish society what's very disturbing
in japan is that some of the
revisionists occupy uh very powerful
positions
in in government or academia they are
not they have not been relegated to the
fringes of society one of them in fact
happens to be a professor of education
at tokyo university which is
considered the most prestigious
university in the country
i personally believe that japan
in the face of this revisionist movement
really needs to do four things if it is
to redeem itself to the international
community first of all it has to give
sincere unequivocal apologies to all
surviving wartime victims instead of the
vague expressions of remorse that have
been made in the past
secondly it should pay in full the
reparations owed to wartime victims
thirdly and
probably most importantly it should stop
censoring or whitewashing its war crimes
in school textbooks
i don't think japan can move forward as
a nation until it educates its young
about the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth about its wartime
aggression starting with nan king any
country that refuses to disclose basic
historical facts to its people a country
that rewrites history for its people is
a country that jeopardizes its very
future as a democracy as well as dooming
itself to potentially repeating the
mistakes of the past
and fourthly i think japan should open
up all its wartime
archives for review by an international
coalition of historians most of these
archives are under lock and key now
after the u.s government in the 1950s
mysteriously returned to japan the
high-level japanese military documents
that american occupation forces had
seized from that country a decade later
and these records returned without being
properly microfilmed
i think we have to be vigilant
as people to ensure that accurate
records of all war crimes be preserved
for a global audience i think steven
spielberg for example has done a
wonderful thing by creating the showa
foundation to film the surviving
testimonials of holocaust victims and i
think that historians should follow his
lead and gather eyewitness accounts of
japanese brutality through an
international oral history videotape
project
which would create an even richer
archive of primary source material for
future books
this would protect the victims from
being written out of history by
future revisionists and there's a very
small window of opportunity to do this
because the victims are dying
most of the ones who had survived the
massacre already in their 80s
it must be stressed that we need such a
repository of history to constantly
remind ourselves of the human potential
for evil japan is not uniquely capable
of these kinds of atrocities nor are
they the first country to evade
punishment for their crimes so we fool
ourselves when we declare that atrocity
and genocide is some kind of unique
aberration in the history of mankind
this is not an isolated incident or some
deadly flaw of one
country or culture but a universal
condition of human nature when we look
back on the 20th century we should
realize this has been the bloodiest
century of all time and in this century
alone we've seen not only attempts to
exterminate entire races through the
holocaust and the armenian genocide but
wholesale massacres of millions of
people by dictators like stalin mao and
pol pot and i think as we approach the
next millennium we would like to believe
that it couldn't happen again but
statistic after statistic cry out to us
that they could and we're still seeing
brutality in the world reminiscent of
that of the rape of name king
in countries like bosnia rwanda and most
recently indonesia where rape is being
used as a weapon to intimidate the local
chinese people as well as to threaten
human rights volunteers from testifying
about these crimes the u.n i really
think that the best antidotes to
genocide
are the truths the forces of truth and
conscience and democracy i think by
honestly viewing the rape of name king
as a cautionary tale in history i think
that the chinese the americans the
japanese and other asian countries can
honestly start to work together towards
this very difficult task of remembrance
so they can work towards a goal that can
promote not hatred but healing and
towards the kind of dialogue that would
help them avoid recreating these
conditions that gave rise to war in the
first place i think as members of the
human race these horrors can't be denied
or forgotten not at the peril of human
civilization itself
i think we all have a moral
responsibility to remind remember such
crimes against humanity and to force
countries like japan to face up to these
crimes and to try to prevent atrocities
like the rape of nanking from ever
happening again thank you so much for
your time today
we have a few minutes for questions now
[Music]
um in in i've been reading about your
book tremendously ever since it came out
um and it seems like you really compiled
a tremendous amount of information thank
you and now hearing from you it also
seems that there was a tremendous amount
of resistance
in in you know allowing this information
to come forth and denying it and i'm
curious as to what kind of resistance
you encountered inc and how you complied
this research and um whether you know
you've been threatened and and just you
know the resistance that you experienced
in putting this whole book together i
haven't received any threats and i
didn't really receive any resistance in
doing research because
a lot of this material was already
available in like american archives and
i when i went to the people's republic
of china i quietly networked with the
scholars and historians who brought me
to some of the the victims so i i didn't
really receive any kind of obstacles um
i did not go to japan but i did
correspond with japanese scholars and
also with a veteran who had actually
perpetrated many of these atrocities and
felt it was important and burdened
himself and through that person i
had a chance to really understand i
think
to a little better degree the the psyche
of some of the soldiers at that time
of course there has been a tremendous
reaction to this book after it came out
i've been lampooned in japanese
political
cartoons and i've been vilified in
editorials
those six revisionist academics who held
that press conference to claim that the
rape and king ever happened they also
called my book
the most outrageous world-class lie
in the spring of this year the japanese
ambassador to the united states even
came out and denounced the book as
one-sided erroneous and filled with
historical inaccuracies
even though he was not able to come up
with a single good example to illustrate
any inaccuracies in my book and of
course what he said
provoked a very strong response for many
organizations and and
like the simon wiesenthal center the
people's republic of china
my publisher several human rights groups
all issued strongly worded protest
letters to the japanese government and
to the ambassador and they also demanded
that he specify what he meant
and at the time
you know i think he even issued a
statement to the effect that it's not
the japanese government's job
to specify what an irish chang's book
is inaccurate that's the job for left up
best left up to historians but
when you make a statement like this i
think you the burden of proof is on you
so
it's no exaggeration to say
that there has been extreme resistance
to this book i mean in japan on the
other hand as i mentioned before in my
speech there was a vocal minority of
people who were already working hard to
raise public awareness on this and of
course they have championed the book so
um
so
this book will be published in japanese
this
uh this winter by the kashiwa shobo
publishing house i think they're
extremely courageous to undertake this
because as one editor wrote to me in the
email they he said it was no
exaggeration that the publishing company
had put themselves in a life-threatening
situation just by publishing this book
so i commend their courage and i think
that once it comes out it should be very
interesting to watch the reaction in
japan
thank you for the tremendous service
you've done thank you
have you been invited to tokyo
by any group
i i haven't received any invitations
that i'm aware of
so far
and among historians have there been
other works
either proceeding or now being worked on
to corroborate and expand upon your work
oh yeah
back in the 1930s there were some
monographs that were published to
reprint some of the documents that were
generated by
by american missionaries and westerners
at the time i don't think they were
widely circulated though but one thing i
didn't mention in my speech was the fact
that there were about about 22 western
foreigners
american missionaries german businessmen
who are also nazi party members
ironically
russians and danes who stayed in the
city to create a safety zone committee
which ultimately sheltered more than 300
000 refugees in uh nan king and and uh
those records are still available and in
fact in many different archives and the
diaries of one of the uh
people there that of a german nazi came
to light after i looked and i found his
descendants you know who were living in
berlin um so
a lot of the primary source material was
always there and this was front page
news in in all the media at the time but
there wasn't that much i think that had
really reached
large numbers of people except for some
of these monographs and in 1996 one
a few months actually before my book
came out um
xi yong and james ian wrote a pictorial
history of the rape of nan king which
comprises mainly of photographs from the
massacre it's a very gruesome book but
it must be read and it's very well
documented so
and there have been two novels too that
have been produced of the rape and
inking but um
in general there hadn't been very much
written about this there's nothing
almost in most school textbooks and um
and it's i think there's gonna be a
flowering of literature on the subject
in in just the next few years last
question yes well what you were saying
um
in contrasting the post-war response
germany japan
is certainly correct there there of
course was as you know a lot of
um
failure
of justice in the europe in the german
context as well
with people like vernon von braun and
all kinds of people oh that's only one
of course didn't but obviously the
larger comparison holds as you say right
i mean there were cold war concerns too
that applied to germany
exactly
um
it's amazing that there hasn't been more
there have been so much on the holocaust
obviously as there should be
so little in contrast
it seems and how is that explicable we
have to keep in mind that china the
people's republic china was literally
sealed off from the rest of the world
for many decades and it was not until
quite recently that an open exchange of
information uh
and an open exchange of you know
commerce and uh really you know
came into being until the 1980s i think
there are many reasons
demographics plays a big role in this i
think that many of the chinese
immigrants who had come to this country
in the 1960s were primarily in
scientific fields and were not in a
position to write a book on the subject
i think too that
that many of the academic historians in
this country had a eurocentric bias when
writing world war ii history and
therefore ignored much of the asian
theater of the war and it's incredible
to me that this happened i mean the
international military tribunal of the
far east was the longest war crimes
tribunal in world history and a reporter
who covered it uh
brachman actually who wrote a book about
the subject said he couldn't believe
there was there was almost nothing in
the literature it's almost like the
whole trial had
fallen into a big black hole
and um
you know and i find it incredible myself
so there's no shortage of primary source
materials but i think
gradually historians are turning their
attention on the subject and i happen to
know of at least
20 books that are probably now
about to be published and are and you
know in in the research stages on the
subject i have two questions for you one
um what do you think of the chances
realistically of the japanese facing up
to this in the next few years and
secondly what is the chinese
government's position in this are they
actively pursuing any effort to get this
the japanese the face up to it well i
don't have a crystal ball i mean i
certainly hope that in the next few
years the the japanese government and
the japanese
people will
you know
take greater responsibility for these
wartime crimes but i mean certainly
there wasn't a record of this for the
last 60 years i don't think it's going
to happen by itself i think it could
only come about as a result of media
pressure political pressure
genuine outrage from other countries and
i i certainly hope that all given time
the majority of the japanese people are
going to say it's time for us to really
make a break with the past and and let's
begin the process of healing by dealing
honestly with with
the war
now
you're asking now what what can be done
what is being done by the people's
republic of china what's their policy
now i think the best thing to do is
simply to ask them directly i think that
their policy has actually become
much more lenient in terms of permitting
widespread rallies to take place in
china to commemorate the victims of the
nanky massacre
there is a name king massacre museum in
the city of nanjing and they have
permitted much more research to be done
in that country and they've actually
at different times when i was being
denounced by academics or the ambassador
i mean the prc government came out twice
to speak out on my behalf which was
quite of a surprise so i think that uh
we may see some with some real shifts in
policy
in that direction too but but i think
the best way to to find out really is to
ask that the people's republic of china
representative directly what what their
policy is
turns out we have the same agent
and uh i just finished writing uh
writing a book that's out
being presented to publishers now about
a man who nobly endured through three
death camps in a death march
i have some idea of the personal cost um
throwing up
sleeplessness i mean there's uh there's
a tremendous amount of of you know
personal erosion that goes on in writing
a book like this absolutely i'd like to
i'd like to know i i i know you had to
keep going and obviously you overcame
whatever whatever obstacles you had i'd
like to know
literally what techniques you used
to keep yourself from from going nuts
and to keep and to keep moving and to
get get the job done it was very
difficult i mean i had to try to train
myself to compartmentalize
the atrocities in one section of my
brain so it wouldn't spill over and
poison the other aspects in my life but
i sometimes i found that simply
impossible that i sometimes went days
without eating anything at all because i
simply lost my appetite i was sick
physically sick almost constantly and i
lost a great deal of weight and hair in
the process of writing this book even my
editor who is now my agent susan rabiner
lost 10 pounds just from the process of
editing this book
and and she became ill in
you know during the last few stages of
the process and
and she couldn't look at the photos i
mean to this day i don't think she's
seen the photos even when i had a
meeting with the art department at basic
books she held up a piece of paper
between herself and the photograph so
she wouldn't even catch a glimpse of it
by accident so it's it's difficult and
um and the only thing that kept me going
was just the knowledge that eventually
this the the news of the massacre would
reach a worldwide audience and the
victims would not be forgotten
thank you
who issued the order the direct order to
kill all captives is there a name that
we can sort of keep in our minds or is
there a group of people well it's
it's very difficult often to assign
responsibility to the highest levels of
power and but it appears that
the order was issued under the command
of prince asaka who was the uncle of
emperor harajito at the time
and prince asaka actually later became
emperor harajito's golfing buddy
and
was never prosecuted or even called in
to testify during the
international military tribunal of the
far east because he was part of the
royal family and therefore was
exonerated from from from all
prosecution
and
and he lived i think
in luxury and and
you know pretty much
it was
was never pretty much punished for what
happened
um have any of the men who participated
expressed remorse and has anyone tried
to tell their story
has repeat the last part of your
question has anyone tried to interview
them or tell their story yes in fact the
the first man to publicly apologize
for his misdeeds during the ripa nanking
was shira azuma
who i think issued that apology back in
the 19 early 1990s probably 1991 if i
remember correctly and for this who
received so many death threats and so
much hate mail in japan that he had to
go into hiding and so he retreated from
society and he now lives uh you know in
a small village where in his house he's
compiled the whole
arsenal weapons to defend himself from
possible ultra-nationalist attack
and he was kicked out of his veterans
association
uh that had actually
you know
welcomed him as a member for more than
half a century and he's been ostracized
by friends but the most disturbing thing
is the fact that he has received
countless death threats but that hasn't
prevented him from unburdening himself
you know in print you know in his
conversations with authors with uh
documentary filmmakers he's even
published his
his diary you know in japanese a diary
he kept during the nanking massacre so i
mean i think he in even though he has
committed these acts of brutality he is
to be commended for his repentant
attitude and there have been some others
too who have done the same who have
spoken out and who have apologized and a
lot of them received constant harassment
from the uh the japanese right wing
yes um you pointed out that no nation no
race no culture is exempt from the kind
of atrocities that are described here
and
we know in the states of course that
it's a very painful process to look back
at milai to look back at
atrocities we've committed but it is it
is accomplished in a free press
i've just moved here from france where
curiously uh it's also difficult for
them to go back even over recent history
the war in algeria even recent scandals
i don't know if many nations none of us
are exempt from the atrocities but i
think you could probably count on the
fingers of one hand
the places where there are there's a
semblance of a free press and the
process of cauterization
is pursued at least by a small number of
journalists in history
i absolutely agree in fact
there are other countries which
not only refuse to acknowledge
wrongdoing or genocide but actually
spend millions of dollars every year
trying to spread propaganda uh that
it never happened i mean japan is one
country but so is turkey you know i mean
turkey has yet to uh to come to grips
with the the armenian genocide another
holocaust which hasn't really penetrated
i think the mass consciousness in this
country uh they the our turkish
government has spent millions of dollars
trying to deny this entirely they've
even funded professorships at leading
american universities including
princeton university and installed
people who do nothing but try to spread
that propaganda and
for that reason i think people it's up
to us as individual human beings as
americans to to remain ever vigilant of
these attempts to rewrite history
because if we don't speak out other
people will try to dismiss a whole body
of evidence altogether
with the policy issue between the
republic of people's republic of china
addressing you know demanding that the
japanese recognize the sins of the past
because that would open up their own
flaws they might have to re-examine some
of the right in general i find that most
most change comes about from individuals
or from grassroots movements it rarely
comes about from government action and
in general
i think
international law is dictated more by uh
money and politics than it is by justice
so i think that individual efforts such
as that of his you know historians
authors or individual activists or
people who are involved in grassroots
movement actually may make more of a
difference than governments themselves
who often
aren't interested in representing the
the needs of the victims or even of
their own constituencies
any other questions
one more
okay we'll squeeze one more in
i'm asking a question on the subject of
the graphics um i was very lucky in new
york to study with um peter watkins who
made the film the war game in england
and it was so graphic that he was banned
so i'm wondering if there ever
is a film made
would you control some of the graphics
somehow or oh if there's a hollywood
studio in hollywood i would hope it'd be
a more
serious documentary made of it but if
the graphics are very strong
well i know you know what i mean like
hiroshima no more
i i i um
that's a very good point um
i i think that that was the big thing
that i wrestled with too was how should
i spare the readers the details you know
but i didn't feel it was impo that it
was
right for me to censor the information
uh i in so many cases brutal images did
appear in my book but some of the most
graphic pictures did not i mean pictures
of women who had been disemboweled after
rape i just i just left out
um and
you're right there's always that
question how much
can people take can the human mind take
and especially when we're dealing with
small children and and you know school
libraries
however in in this case in the case with
the rape and nan king i mean i've had
many people not just from like the
colleges and universities but from high
schools and grade schools
teachers who come out and buy the book
and say they're going to show it to the
students and they don't feel it's too
graphic they think it's necessary for
the students to learn what really
happened so
it's
it's it's always it's always difficult
but in the end i do think that this is a
book that is
it's it's meant for adult consumption
not not for
for children to read and um you just you
just do the best and hope you've made
the right decisions thank you very much
thank you
thank
you much thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen chang
will autograph books and be able to
speak with you personally
outside in the autograph area that's
author irish chang in the miami book
fair international as our live coverage
nine hours worth continues today on book
tv we're going to give you a sense today
of what it's like to be here with
thousands of south floridians as they
attend the 15th annual book fair in
miami here's the schedule of what's
coming up later in the day
in about 45 minutes you'll hear from
jaffa elliot she's being share our
in-depth look at democratic presidential
candidate al gore
it airs at 8 pm eastern here on c-span
now a discussion on asian-american
contributions to american life
in may the committee of 100 hosted a
conference in new york city which
brought together leaders in the asian
american community
this panel included author iris chang
and aids researcher david ho time
magazine's man of the year
we thank all of you for your patience on
this late saturday afternoon
we hope the panel that's about to be
presented will give truth to the
proposition that the last is the best
this panel was formed to outline asian
american contributions to american
society
many speakers over the last two days
have referred in various ways to the
historical presence of asian americans
and particularly chinese americans and
their contributions
our children obviously learn in their
history classes about the contributions
made in such industries as mining and
the railroads and the agriculture by the
first generation of immigrants
but as anna chennault's comments a
moment ago outlined
we have an enormous reservoir of talent
among the chinese-american community
today
each generation of immigrants and the
children of those immigrants faces
unique challenges unique risks unique
opportunities
i think it is worthwhile mentioning that
in the post-war years the generation of
the so-called chinese-american baby
boomers
the generation of chinese parents then
had limited confidence in general in
their own english communication skills
had a high anxiety about the state of
race relations and racial discrimination
in america
and
in the power of education particularly
in science in technology and in medicine
as a consequence
those chinese americans who came of age
in the 1970s and 1980s
tended in disproportionate numbers to
enter the fields of science engineering
and medicine and to study in those
fields at least as undergraduates
but times have changed and america has
changed
today
many of us have access to much better
education in communications
the barriers of racial discrimination
have come down very significantly
and there are multiple paths now open to
success in this american society
science medicine and engineering are
certainly still respected but it is no
longer perceived by chinese americans as
the only path
[Music]
our panel today
reflects and celebrates the diversity of
paths to success
and paths for contribution to american
society and we have deliberately chosen
i think a very diverse group
representing the media and motion
pictures corporate finance
medical research and history and
journalism among others i will introduce
briefly the entire panel and then turn
it over to eric liu who will moderate
the panel for us today
i will not
embarrass either the speakers or myself
by trying to recite the many
accomplishments of this distinguished
group
their full biographies are in your
program materials
let me begin with oscar tang who is to
my immediate left he is a member of the
committee of 100 and a co-founder of the
committee of 100. i think it is fair to
characterize oscar as one of wall
street's most successful financial
professionals now a director of invest
formerly known as new england investment
companies with over 130 billion dollars
under investment
prior to that he was the co-founder
president and ceo of rei shin tang an
outstanding investment advisory firm
he is a member of numerous corporate
boards and non-profit boards including
koa holdings and the metropolitan museum
as well as his alma mater the phillips
academy
for those of you who are parents and
anxious to prime your children towards
school he is a graduate of yale and the
harvard business school
eric liu was next in line and further
down
is an author and journalist he is
currently a contributor to msnbc and a
writer for slate magazine
he is an author of the best-selling
accidental asian which is an
extraordinary collection of essays on
the development of racial consciousness
and racial identity in modern america
he has held numerous positions in
washington as well having served as a
former speechwriter for president
clinton director of legislative affairs
at the national security council and as
a legislative assistant to senator david
bourne
he is a graduate of yale as well
next we have janet yang
who is also a member of the committee of
100
she and her partner lisa henson
are now
the owners of the manifest film company
which is one of hollywood's outstanding
production companies they've already
produced two films savior which is
highly topical in light of our conflict
in kosovo currently starring dennis
quaid and was the co-producer of zero
effect
from 1989 to 96 she was president of
islam oliver stone's film production
company where she handled all film
development and production and she was
especially recognized for her production
of people versus larry flynn
prior to those positions she had an
extensive career in both television and
film
always linked always linked by careful
and considered connections between
hollywood and china which probably
reflects the fact that she has a ba from
brown university in chinese studies as
well as an mba from colombia
iris chang is next in line
on the panel she is a member of the
committee of 100 and is really one of
the country's now rising stars in
history and and uh
popular history in particular she has
two books to her credit threat of the
silkworm and the new york times
bestseller rape of nanjing which she has
almost pioneered single-handedly in
bringing to light the atrocities
committed by japanese troops in china
and during the second world war
she is a recipient of the macarthur
foundation award and she is currently
working on a narrative history of
chinese in america
she has her ba from the university of
illinois and has done graduate work at
johns hopkins university
finally to show that we are not giving
up on science medicine and technology
altogether
we have dr david hall
also a member of the committee of 100.
he is currently the ceo and scientific
director for the aaron diamond aids
research center in new york
and also i believe concurrently a
professor of medicine at rockefeller
he is widely acknowledged as one of the
world's foremost medical researchers on
aids including the genetic basis of hiv
and hiv replication
he is a recipient of the ernst young
award in medicine he has been named by
time magazine as man of the year in 1996
and has been elected to the prestigious
institute of medicine at the national
academies of science
prior to this set of honors he was also
involved in clinical and research
positions at the harvard medical school
ucla and nyu
he is currently serving as a member of
the board of trustees at his alma mater
cal tech and also at the harvard board
of overseers
he received his bs summa [ __ ] laude in
physics from caltech and his md degree
from the harvard medical school
i hope i've kept within carolyn's
instructions for a rapid introduction
and eric i turn it over to you thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much and
we will perhaps and hopefully be joined
as well by david henry huang
and
we'll leave a seat for him
at the table
uh i'm just going to
offer a couple of introductory remarks
about the the
topic that we all are going to discuss
and converse about today
and
really then try to
open it up to conversation among the
panelists and
ultimately to conversation hopefully
among
all of us here who are gathered today
we've come here today i think at a just
a fascinating time
in talking and thinking about the place
that chinese americans occupy in this
country's life
and in this country's imagination
uh and i think that uh
we're gathered at a time when asian
americans and chinese americans in
particular
are getting more active than ever and
more present than ever
in every walk in every realm of american
life
from the arts to business to politics to
history to the sciences
what have you
you cannot turn a page in the newspaper
now
you cannot read
your own trade journal whatever
profession you might be in without
encountering names and faces and voices
of asian americans and chinese americans
and so
i think that
unquestionably the influence of asian
americans in this country in every realm
of life in this country is on the rise
and this panel really does testify to
that this extraordinary panel before we
go any farther i just want to uh indulge
myself this is moderator's prerogative
and once again applaud our panel for
being here today
[Applause]
at the same time that
the influence of asian americans is
certainly on the rise
what we've seen as well
is a sense in which this idea of asian
influence this idea of asian
contributions asian involvement
has brought out
a certain darker aspect as well
in the way that non-asians tend to talk
about asian americans and we've seen
that over these last few years alone
whether it was in the context of the
campaign finance scandals
where asian money
kind of fear and specter of asian money
was was inflated in many regards
we're seeing it now in these allegations
of espionage
questions of loyalty
we see it even in the realm i think of
higher education where asian americans
have made perhaps their most visible
mark and on many campuses questions as
to whether there are too many haitians
whether there's too much asian influence
whether there is
a presence and influence out of
proportion
and so i think as i say this is just a
fascinating time for us to be thinking
about these questions of contributions
of asian-american contributions to
american society
i think it's
just a critical time right now to
explore the full breadth and the full
meaning
of what that contribution is
as i say on an individual level as our
panelists testify to there are countless
asian americans who are making a huge
difference in changing our culture and
our society
but i think perhaps one of the greatest
and more profound contributions that
asian americans and chinese americans in
particular are making
is one to the very idea of what it means
to be american
it's not so much about what's happening
in this field or that profession
it's not so much about what individual
accomplishments we might be able to rack
up
but i think what chinese americans are
doing just by virtue
of getting more more involved in every
realm of american life
is to add a much needed degree of
complexity
to all the conversations that go on in
this country about race and identity and
about that most fundamental question
that comes up time and again
which is who is us
who is us
and so i think that one of the things
that
this panel does
apart from their individual
accomplishments is embody that spirit
embody that spirit of really trying to
push the boundaries of what it means to
be an american
push the boundaries and the
understandings of people of every
background
so that people's expectations people's
ideas
of what's right and proper for asian
americans and chinese americans to be
doing are opened and expanded as well
so that somebody could walk into this
room this afternoon or see a tape of
this event later on today
and we could reach that point through
the actions of these people and others
where they will see a room like this and
think first
think without thinking
there is a room full of americans
i think that is the contribution that
these people are ultimately pushing us
toward and i think that all of them in
their own respective ways are pioneers
and really people who have been giving
voice
i think that's the common theme and
thread that really runs through
the work and the accomplishments of all
of them and i'd like to really begin the
conversation among the panelists
on this question of
voice and
role and place in space
and i'd like to pose a question all of
you can
take a take a stab at this just
i'd like to know and i think it would be
of great interest to the people who are
involved here today
in your own walk of life in your own
field
uh
what kinds of challenges and obstacles
that a
asian americans face
what kinds of
obstacles
have you faced as an asian american and
what kinds of things have you felt like
you've had to do or wanted to do to
negotiate and navigate those kinds of
obstacles whether they're professional
whether they're cultural whatever they
may be so that as you've been these
pioneers in your in your various fields
uh you can perhaps shed some light to
the many others who are here today and
and who are listening to what you have
to say and why don't we start janet
with you i know that
when we spoke earlier we were talking
about the theme of role models
and janet is no doubt a role model to
many many people asian
or not women or not but particularly
asian americans
who are thinking about hollywood and the
media
and and when i asked her about that i
asked her who had been her role models
and janet why don't you tell us what
what you had to say about that
well to answer the first part of your
question i think growing up i was very
much
a part of a
victim i suppose of a perception of
asian americans that has certainly been
contradicted by this conference
asian americans or chinese americans are
shy no we are not we are
if you heard charles wong last night you
know he's we're very funny
we are quiet no we're not we're very
verbal very verbose in fact
we are
somehow retiring we are no if you see
why y'all perform he's brash and
expressive if you heard anna chanel you
would say no we're not even modest we
are we're out there but this is not what
people think of us somehow there's a
huge discrepancy between
the reality that exists today and what
people perceive
of us as being and i think this has a
lot to do with the images that are on
the big screen and the little screen i
know for myself growing up there
virtually existed nothing in the way of
interesting roles for asians and i think
it wasn't until i
lived in china in the early 80s that i
myself was struck by this and i thought
my god here i'm living in a country
where chinese faces occupy every
every walk of life on the screen they
are of all different personalities as
diverse a group as one can imagine and
yet these were not represented in the
west and so it was really china and and
the chinese movies initially and
bringing chinese movies to the united
states and eventually putting
chinese and asian faces and asian-themed
themes on the screen that motivated me
to get into the movie business i did not
fancy myself as a hollywood producer at
all but it was it was tough going
because back then in the 80s there we
were fighting
a lot of stereotypes and
and
i
really didn't have a role model to
answer the second part of your question
it was
there simply wasn't a path that existed
that i could sort of emulate i was
following my nose i had a passion to do
something i had no idea what was leading
to
and i don't think one could chart
uh sort of a progression in a very
logical fashion
but
i am now more committed than ever
to
the idea of building a bridge through
film and television and
knowing that this is really a language
that speaks to people around the world
well i think
so much of what you said i think
applies to just about everybody here and
i'm curious iris
these same questions about
not necessarily having a clear path set
out for you or these kind of role models
i mean the kind of work that you've done
uh in bringing so much
uh historical you know significant
historical material to to light into the
consciousness not only of uh chinese
americans but again to everybody in this
country did you feel like as you set out
to do that um that you were really on
your own in a sense what kind of models
were you following as you decided that
uh you wanted to do this and you know it
goes to what janet said you know these
stereotypes about asian americans not uh
wanting to express their voice i can't
think of somebody anybody more than iris
who's really gone out there and made her
voice heard thank you i i and i can't
agree more i think that the stereotype
of the chinese not having a voice not
really wanting a voice is completely
false there were many chinese-americans
when i was growing up who wanted to be
writers unfortunately there weren't role
models
i knew of no
chinese-american
authors at the time when i was growing
up who i could look towards as somebody
could emulate so i found role models but
they
had to be people who were not
necessarily asian americans
i was not only concerned when i was
growing up about the absence of role
models in literature in american
literature
but also the absence of chinese
americans in the whole realm of u.s
history
my third book is going to be a narrative
history of the chinese in america and
what alarms me is that many historians
tell me the last 50 years of chinese
american accomplishment
is is practically
not existent at all in the historical
literature
and
just being at this conference for the
last few days
has made me realize that this is a you
know a serious problem because i see so
many leaders at this conference
in in the sciences in business and the
arts in so many different fields and yet
it has been almost completely neglected
by the historical community but i think
it is a responsibility that we have as
chinese americans and as chinese
american leaders to make ourselves heard
documents that you have press clippings
you know any kind of sense of
accomplishment should be recorded and
made available to historians
i also became aware when i was growing
up that there was very little
information often about
chinese history in general
for example the my second book the rape
of nang king describes uh
one of the worst atrocities of world
history how more than 300 000 chinese
were brutally slaughtered and raped in
the capital of china 60 years ago now i
learned about this only because my
parents told me about the name king
massacre when i was a little girl but i
was shocked when i went into the school
libraries and all the public libraries
in my hometown i could not find a word
on the subject in english furthermore my
my school teachers had no clue as to
what i was talking about and so i think
it is the responsibility of chinese
americans to make sure that this is
documented that these stories are told
and passed on to the next generation
because if we don't do it i don't think
anyone else is going to do it for us
well iris the there's no question that
you've been doing it and i think that uh
you know everybody here in this room
would be grateful for what you've been
been doing and i think the uh the
question you raise the theme that you
raise of responsibility
uh is one that i think runs throughout
this whole kind of dialogue
and and david you know i'm just
wondering i think that uh certainly in
the work that
you've been doing
which is so
centrally important and in so many ways
so bound up with social issues uh and a
sense of social and moral responsibility
i'm wondering just you know as you've
gone about that work what kinds of um
when you even set out on doing that kind
of work
again to start out with the initial
question what sense of uh obstacles did
you feel like you faced uh or that you
see today other asian americans facing
uh in your field which is the field
where still so many uh of the brightest
and most able asian americans are
heading toward
and what sense of responsibility does
that raise
in your mind
well perhaps i'm i'm the only
stereotypic asian american
here on this
um
i hope i'm not on the panel because i
got
good grades in school and he aced the
s.a.t and went to mit caltech and to
boot
got a doctorate degree from harvard
i think i hope i'm here because
everybody's parents are proud on your on
your parents behalf
i must say mine are proud as well
but but like the rest of the panelists
here i pursued my passion and i think i
worked hard and
and did it well and and hopefully uh
that work is is now making a difference
as with respect to the question asked
about what asian scientists face in this
country what are the obstacles
obviously you know that
asian americans
among the very best in science
many are doing
outstanding work
i would say
contributed substantially
to put america first in science
but
if you if you look at the very top of
academia
particularly in the sciences and
biomedical field
asian americans are underrepresented
and i often ask why that is
uh and and thought about my own role in
in that context
and i think there are
there are some reasons for that i think
it was said earlier that perhaps asians
are quieter and people are
asked to
be more modest
while that may not be entirely
true for this panel it certainly
is quite true for many who chose the
sciences
were right and wrong are clear-cut
whereas in other fields
right and wrong
tend to be more subjective
and so there's actually a seating that's
self-imposed or imposed by the by our
culture
and in addition for many asian american
scientists in this country there's the
further problem of a slight language gap
we're not as articulate in english as
those
uh who were born here
and and i want to hear emphasize the
point that charles wong brought up
yesterday
and that is
the that is what what is happening to a
large number of asian american
scientists is that they do the work well
but they can't present the work in an
articulate manner
and and thus
these
individuals are doomed to be technicians
as he put it and i certainly see that in
my father's generation my own generation
and now as i look to my younger
colleagues that is certainly true
but there is also another factor and and
that is
the the unwinning unwillingness
to take leadership roles
there's something about those who went
into science they say
leadership that involves politics and
somehow that's dirty
um i certainly don't feel that way but
there is a strong sentiment in that
regard and also leadership means making
decisions
and decisions means at times you have to
take risks
and
i think that's why while chinese are
known for their
risk-taking in business and and
certainly in las vegas
it's it's not a common practice in
science
and so
so there's a there's an excessive
avoidance of risk and and as as uh
hero shapiro from princeton put it so
nicely uh that
is wrong and that is an application of
leadership and acceptance of mediocrity
and so
i think in my own uh career in science i
diverted from the stereotype a bit in in
that i was a
uh
willing to
take certain positions on science policy
and also
at least in my small capacity as the
leader of a small research institute
run the institute and also speak out on
on the national level
and and
lately i've been given the platform and
you bring up responsibility with any
recognition that i've gotten
that comes with responsibility and my
responsibilities
is is number one to speak about what i
do and and how enormous this epidemic
is that that we face in in the problem
aids
i was very pleased that jim wolfinson
at lunch mentioned
just a few of the statistics it's an
enormous problem that threatens our
entire planet
and and i take that as my responsibility
and use my
you know recent recognition to speak out
on that particular issue and at the same
time i also use that platform to speak
as an asian american on on issues of
concern to our community
well you you uh
speak
in particular about these questions of
leadership and uh and getting your voice
out there and the question of risk and
risk aversion
i don't know what oscar's las vegas
activities are but i certainly know that
uh in the realm of business he's he must
have
accepted a certain high tolerance for
risk because he's had a great degree of
success and uh oscar we'd just like to
hear a little bit i think on those same
themes and questions uh
do you feel like the business world the
business environment
is one which has less or more
or just a different kind of
obstacles for asian and chinese
americans
well perhaps i could first
go back a little bit and and
iris mentioned the
issue of history
i guess
first of all i'm at least half a
generation older than
my fellow panelists here
and
uh perhaps have a little bit of
different background in the sense that i
came here
at a young age which many david i know
also came
at the age of 12 but i came
and
in 1949 um
at the age of 11 and was totally
immersed into
a american
loca really in vermont
in a small town in vermont so
i had to if you will
learn to live within a totally american
environment
and i think the history that i'm
referring to is that
as a child as a student in china
i learned
two things which is that i was sort of
always taught that being chinese that
gave me tremendous
reservoir of
of
cultural background
and that i had the potential to be
like many chinese if you will the
potential to really
excel
in many ways i don't know if i had that
capability or not but i was sort of
taught that number one
that chinese had somehow a
strength and a superior culture of
belief in education
and family support that was one part of
it
then
even in fourth and fifth grade you read
the history
about china especially the last 150
years of china's history
and
and you learn as a child that something
was wrong that
that china's history
if you will that having this
distinguished past somehow
things hadn't gone very well
and
in fact i lived in the french sector of
shanghai just imagine that what that
meant
if you are a chinese person and you
lived
in by the time i was
going around i guess these signs didn't
exist but i was told that there were
clubs around in the french sector that
had signs that said
you know no chinese or dogs allowed
so
i had a sort of a mixed message and i
came into an environment here and i
should tell you i came in luckily to
primarily an educational
environment
really schools and colleges and so forth
so they were really very very tolerant
but there were no
virtually no other chinese in these
communities at that point
a few perhaps nothing like it is now
so i guess i had to learn
to um operate
just as an individual i didn't
particularly
think in terms of being a chinese person
and what were you and that's really the
the
so it was
less a lack of a
there was no role model if you will
but perhaps the strength that came from
knowing the fact that i come from this
culture
and this really rich
past
and that
that that should have given me the
potential to
to uh uh
if i worked at it that perhaps i could
succeed
so that's really the the the way i've
looked at it i think that in speaking
about
some of the characteristics i think that
i should also mention that i operated in
in environment
which tended to be more entrepreneurial
in other words for whatever reason
i chose not to go into a let's say a
large structured business type of
environment
i think wall street
tends to operate more on at least i felt
on ideas
and
going back to what david was saying
you have to believe in the power of your
ideas and if you believe in the power of
the ideas i think that you have to be
able to present them
you have to articulate them
and convince other people that these
ideas have merit
and that we should all pursue them
whether it be in scientific areas or in
business areas
and then you have to be willing to act
on them and that's the risk taking
element
which is that that you have to put your
um reputation your
your career
what will you to explain them and then
to to lead
an organization to act on that and to
take the risk
of being wrong if you will in that
process so
i think that is the element of
risk-taking which is i think a very
important part
i might also mention that
we shouldn't make too much of the
limitations we should really celebrate
the opportunities if you look at
the
educational background of this panel
you cannot say that the
opportunities are not available to us i
mean the educationally
it is open
to us it i have always felt this
and so it's more important
to me that that we participate that we
strike out
and we assume that we're going to be
treated
fairly
sometimes you may not be but if you
start with the idea that you're not
going to be treated fairly you're not
going to venture out if you don't
venture out you're never going to
have the chance
for your own talents to be to be uh
used if you will
well i think that's absolutely right and
you know among the many
points that you bring out is this whole
question which you know i think
everybody here can speak to about uh
following a structure or a network
versus striking out on your own and i
think certainly you know i'd love to
hear janet i mean what do you think
about that and the kind of challenges in
hollywood i mean i think that in one
sense can define the very split of what
hollywood is about and uh and how
you've
tried to figure out which way to go and
that
in that choice and how others have
well i'll tell you a funny story um
i was battling among other things my
parents owned prejudice about
the arts in general as you all probably
know in confucian society it's sort of
the bottom of the totem pole to
want to work in the arts film certainly
or anything of that nature
so they were quite concerned and they
were doubly concerned when i became very
interested in studying chinese history
and language and literature although
they wanted to raise me as a good
chinese girl growing up
and wanted me to go to saturday school
and study chinese when i became actually
serious about it later in life they
started to panic because they thought
what what are you going to do with that
and when i went to live in china they
considered that really extreme and none
of these pieces were fitting together
when i became interested in film then
they just became apoplectic i mean what
was this all going to amount to
so there was that constant not knowing
where it was going i mean again this was
a time where people weren't paying much
attention to china on a on a political
level particularly much less on a
cultural level
and
where i
really again had no structure whatsoever
to follow
i at a certain point i was approached by
steven spielberg to work with him on his
film and part of the sun in china which
was
purely because i had been traveling back
and forth to china and i was simply the
only person in hollywood that you know
could speak chinese and actually knew
the chinese film industry and was
working on a studio and that was a name
that
kind of got them interested a little bit
when
i went to work at mca universal and i
was able to present them with
the
you know company profile and the fact
that i had 17 000 employees that got
them kind of excited you know i might
get stock options and all that but it
wasn't until i was in that structure did
it suddenly seem like a legitimate job
to them after that i went to join oliver
stone and once again their faces fell
and said well who's oliver stone and how
many people are going to be in that
company and we had a little office on
the beach in venice and
again they couldn't understand they
follow my sort of roller coaster path
and really the the industry in many ways
especially from my end of it
it tends to be a bit gypsy like we're
we're a bunch of vagabonds we have um if
we're lucky we get our overhead paid for
but really we're living from project to
project and there's a lot of dead time
in between and we are constantly in a
state of flux if not risk
so i think it takes it does take
courage i suppose first for some people
to feel like oh there isn't this
institutional
kind of backing
you know to what to what we do and it
and i think that one of some of the
censorship that we all face is this kind
of self-censorship can we do it do we
have the courage to
to proceed is this going to be okay you
know what happens if we fail there's
such a high bar placed on the children
of chinese parents my experiences and
and and is it is it we don't get much
encouragement from them and they have
very odd ways of sort of measuring our
success and i think that the only thing
that makes them feel at ease now is that
they know that i have made you know good
income on certain movies and so they
feel okay i'm secure because ultimately
what they want is a feeling that we will
be okay we can raise our children
and you know not be thrown out on the
street but um
it's it's a state of mind as well it's a
it's an entrepreneurial the industry is
going through some major fluctuations
right now it is very unstable even the
big institutions like and universal in
fact is practically on the point of
bankruptcy at this point it's not able
it's been telling its producers on the
lot and i t at expensive restaurants and
you can imagine how that sits with
these producers which is you know often
considered producer often considered to
have a life of extravagance so it's it's
you know it's one that causes you one is
forced to be kind of a little bit
ahead of the curve on the cutting edge
and figuring out what is going on you
can't ever really get comfortable
so
i personally i maybe one day i'll go
back to working at a studio i'm not sure
if that will be the case or not but
there is
nothing for certain and your your career
depends a lot on your last film
and there's so many highs and lows and
as a basic business investment
it's risky it is very very high risk
something like one in ten films actually
makes money
and you know if you can getting a film
done any film is extremely difficult so
you're kind of you're always living on
the edge a little bit and for me i think
i i like that it sort of keeps me on the
edge and keeps me french
fresh you can't really get complacent
but it's very very not confusion
it's very and i think one of the
challenges that asian americans chinese
americans face is how to take the best
of those confucian values and and not
kind of blindly superimpose them on our
society they don't really apply and the
things that work better in america are
innovation
and you know you don't as we talked
about last night you don't need the
degrees in fact hollywood if anything is
is more of a meritocracy than just about
any other place i can think of because
people really don't care if you've ever
done anything before it's what can you
do now they don't care who your father
is they don't care if you've had their
degrees none of this matters i mean i
think i was probably prepared for
hollywood you know in certain ways
because i grew up in a jewish
neighborhood i happened to go to an all
boys prep school phillips exeter academy
in phillips academy and maybe this was
some preparation but ultimately
you know i was doing it by the seat of
my pants and and um
that's how it will probably continue to
be forever
well i think everybody here can uh
identify with that whole question of
uh
culture
and values and the values uh that
our families and our parents
immerse us in and whether and how uh
those values influence our own choices
about the ways that we go about doing
things i mean one word that you said
when you were saying and i looked
immediately to iris was the word
self-censorship
uh because i think they're
certainly in taking undertaking a
project like the rape of nanking
there would be all kinds of pressure
whether coming from self or from outside
absolutely to censor and to keep the
voice down and not to make a stink and
that is inherent i think in the nature
of the project but i think a lot of that
is inherent too
in the kind of values and cultural
behaviors that a lot of us have been uh
so steeped in and i'm wondering if you
could just tell a little bit about those
definitely intentions well i think that
in order to be an author you have to be
independent-minded and very very strong
because as an author you don't have any
infrastructure unless you become a
writer in residence at a university
but um if you leave the uh
the protection let's say
oh can you hear me
yeah
if you leave the protection
of the newspaper the magazine the
university you're really on
and
i have to say that being an author is
one of the most intellectually
liberating career i've ever undertaken
but it's also the riskiest
and i guess i was very fortunate in that
my parents
were always very supportive of my
my career
like many asian parents they stressed
education and harder work right from the
beginning
including uh
you know
you know literature or literary pursuits
i think unlike many parents though they
were intensely idealistic i grew up in a
very academic town i grew up in the
university town of champaign-urbana
illinois and there was a sense i think
in that community that
that the quest for beauty and truth
was really a more noble calling than the
pursuit of of money
um this could be because most people in
champaign urbana weren't making that
much money but um
on the other hand there was that sense
that we were above you know money we
were above politics it wasn't just my
parents i think that this was kind of a
sense that we had in that
whole town so um
in my family in particular i think we
were really encouraged
to
question authority to not only question
authority but question the prevailing
wisdom of the era to ask questions
and to uh to not be afraid to think
on your own
and it was considered really one of the
highest honors to add to the the body of
human knowledge i in fact i remember
even my father was very critical of
something that confucius had said he
once
said you know confucius said that a
woman's highest virtue is her ignorance
he said that's just ridiculous
and so i think my parents were in a
certain way they they were steeped in
asian values but they were also very
progressive and and
very liberal
and so um there was a sense that you
just don't tailor your beliefs to fit
this season's political fashions you
think on your own you've got to believe
in you that you can make a difference
and so i think that it was it was this
sense that i had which which we were
also cultivated to believe that this was
also a very chinese belief you know that
scholars are well respected in china and
and uh
you know they
especially the the you know the the
literary types the the philosophers that
this was something that was a noble
calling and i think that's really what
sustained me throughout throughout my
career but i think you're you're
absolutely right you
have to be very
uh you have to be very strong because
um it's a solitary profession
and
when you write a book you are constantly
subject to scrutiny and criticism
but in the end i think it's the it's the
richest life that you can have and um
the important thing i think is to
realize that in this country in uh in
the united states you really can't
starve it would take
i think a lot of a lot of effort to
starve to death and and you really do
have
a benefit of a free press in this
country which is not necessarily
something that you have in other
countries um
the the publisher in japan for example
that
um had wanted to translate my book the
rape of mankind has you know he's
they've received threats and so
it's it's not something i think you
really can take for granted in this
country
and so i i i really do believe that one
of the reasons why
um
you know that many chinese parents
discourage
their children from going into
i think literature or film making or
anything unconventional i don't think it
comes from a fundamental disrespect
because i think a lot of them do realize
the importance of the arts i do think
that it's it's this fear of going into
what is political you see i think this
is historically rooted in in their own
backgrounds that there's a good
historical reason for this most
of the parents of my generation
um
most of the
parents of my my friends and and people
who were of my parents generation
um
had to flee china uh in in
1949 to escape communism and they
really
lived in fear of
of you know often persecution
and i think there was a sense that all
of them had gotten burned
because they had gone into politics
and and so
my parents told me you know when they
were growing up in taiwan
their parents and other parents were
saying to their children do not go into
politics and they were encouraged to go
into the sciences because the future lay
in the united states where you could
become successful and also secure by
remaining
apolitical and i think that kind of fear
of speaking out of taking a leadership
role of of becoming political that that
has actually still it's it's go it's
gone from one generation to the next and
i think it's it's not so much that the
chinese aren't willing to take
leadership positions i think it is
rooted in in basically the fear of what
can happen if you lose out on a
political battle because i mean in this
country if you lose an election you you
know you lose an election but i think in
this in another country if you lose out
on a political game you could lose your
life political so um
you know it's no uh you know it's no
trivial matter so i think this is one
reason why people often feel held back
from having from speaking out when they
really should
well i think it's just fascinating what
you say i mean one of the
the and what you say i think applies not
only to the realm of um
politics strictly as politics or even
writing
or even journalism but i think one of
the uh most important lessons that this
generation of chinese americans may have
to offer to
to our parents and to our
contemporaries
is just that no matter what walk of life
you're in and i think david certainly
can attest to this
that you can find ways to step into the
public square
that doesn't mean running for office
necessarily doesn't mean uh you know
writing a polemical uh you know article
or anything like that uh but i think
that uh what it does mean is just
getting into the habits
uh all of us uh
of being able to step into the public
square and david i'm just wondering how
it was
um you know to the great degree that
you've done that how it was that you
came to those habits were those habits
that you stumbled upon were those habits
that others cultivated in you
that sense that i wasn't just going to
stay
and do my thing but i was going to do my
thing
and a think about the wider consequences
of it and b
speak to the wider society about it i
mean what was it that
gave you that sense of capacity
i'm i'm not sure there was one single
thing
i
pursue what i did i pursue research on
viruses particularly on the aids virus
build my projects build my
program and and and the institute
and gradually as you
get into the science
and establish yourself
you you have to get involved in the in
the sense that
there is a national aids policy
and if you are a significant player you
have to have some sort of opinion
and you can't just
hold back and say i'm a scientist i'd
have no opinion on
on
controversial issues
concerning condom distribution
concerning needle exchange or the
the inequities between us and and
the developing countries i think you
have to get into the fray
uh once
you're in really into the field
uh so it was a gradual process i would
say particularly as i assume the
leadership of the aaron diamond aids
research center
and particularly as it gained prominence
in the field everybody wanted your
opinion and
one had to make the decision at that
point should i stay a pure scientist and
pure in quotations or
get into dirty politics at times and and
i could still recall
a few years ago at the age of 40
trying
to criticize the national institute of
health with respect to its
distribution of money for aids research
it was clear that the emphasis was not
proper
and by
clearly stating so in 1992 if in a lot
of people but i think i was in the in
the right position
and at that point it i could see that
people
even though they they hear
scientific presentations from chinese
american frequently they don't generally
hear
comments on policy issues from chinese
american scientists and
and i could still recall institute
directors and and directors of the
national institute of health saying who
is this guy
but i think
that's how i
gradually
got into this process and and realized
it is a responsibility what i do
is funded by public money largely
and and
it is my responsibility to to tell the
public what i do and also to express uh
my opinion
on how certain things should proceed
well i'm wondering whether any of the
panelists just have thoughts
i want to the the word responsibility
has come up time and time again in this
conversation and i'm wondering if
anybody wants to just tackle the
question concretely
of how uh those of us who are
in leadership positions can actually
discharge that responsibility i mean in
your particular walk of life what is it
that you think
you could do or that you're already
doing
um to
you know number one set an example and
lead by example but number two to build
concrete uh bridges and connections uh
to
other parts of american society and also
to the next generation of uh uh chinese
americans and then uh you know as jim
wolfensohn was saying today the next
generation of people who will be coming
to events uh like this one within your
given fields and you know anyone if you
have any thoughts on this i think it'd
be very valuable to talk concretely
about the things that we
we all of us in this room can be doing
to build those kind of bridging
connections
well i think one thing that
i think it's important to
recognize
that we are chinese
but it's also important
to recognize that we live in america
and that
by and large
you're going to succeed
in an american environment
i think we talk a lot about
things like the glass ceiling and i'm
certain that these things exist
but
more and more the society is becoming
more open
in even in say an area such as the
capital markets
and enterprise business enterprises
large established companies and such
structures
are in
in turmoil
as newer forces come along
and the new forces
can become very major very quickly
and the capital markets are getting more
and more open
to finance these new
enterprises new
ideas
so that what you're dealing with is is a
society if you will which is very much
coming our way
so again
we should focus
on that side as opposed to
the limitations which granted do exist
don't focus so much on the glass
ceilings focus really on the
opportunities
because they're coming our way and i
think it's important
that
while we keep our roots if you will
understand where we come from
the society that we come from and
support organizations such as the
committee of 100 or other
institutions that that promote chinese
culture
chinese values or chinese heritage if
you will it's also important to
i think be really part of mainstream
america
uh after all the institutions here are
going to be primarily
american
and
and
you know they do give us
the great opportunities that we have and
it's important that we
we return that in some way
and to me one of the things is is is you
know so it's important to play a civic
role
in our society
and to return something to that society
in the general terms
so
my feeling is that you know
i have to do both in other words
to return something both to the
chinese-american
our own identity
the
art and the cultural institutions which
i think have been so enriching for all
of us
to help educate americans about chinese
art and culture background history what
will you
but it's also important to play uh a
cent
role in the central institutions
to become
america if you were to become
part-american in that process
so
whether it be in civic activities or in
philanthropy i think it's important that
we participate in
that i feel like i'm in a position where
i'm very much part of mainstream america
or delivering product to mainstream
america
but i'm also in a position where i could
be serving the community better by
making films like the july club i'd like
to make another film like that
however as a community we're we don't
yet really back the arts we get a lot of
finger pointing we get a lot of this
doesn't look good we don't like this
role we don't like that movie and
frankly it scares people off
and there isn't enough support coming
from our own community for films that
are made or could be made
and primarily this would come in the
form of financial backing if people want
to see movies about ourselves on the
screen we probably have to go much
further in financing those films because
for the time being we are still battling
the stereotypes and there is no real
motivation especially with a lot of this
kind of finger pointing for the people
who currently write the checks to say oh
let's take a gamble and and make this
film that has some asian content or some
you know
some other seemingly political content
that serves the asian community it just
is not likely to happen it happens
almost by accident with the in the case
of the joy luck club it happened to be a
best-selling book it's not a film again
that one could easily go out and
convince other people to do although it
did well it was an all asian cast and
all female cast
we haven't seen many of those happen yet
so we need to work together more to
figure out what is our
how can we do how can we share in each
other's resources and how can how can we
join hands better and how can we
encourage our children to become good
screenwriters because it's it's much
easier to criticize than it is to create
we need great screenplays with stories
that would be appealing and accessible
to american audiences as well as
international audiences and asian
american audiences
that are written maybe by chinese
americans or asian americans but they
need to be encouraged to do so there
needs to be some incentive and we need
we need to back it up you know we
there's there's
you know in a room like this
there are ways in which we could
actually do that but we haven't
actually done it yet so
we
we could
we could be going a lot further and it's
it's a it's a battle every day that any
producer faces getting somebody to write
a check for your movie it's so many
pieces have to become a line the stars
have to come together
any number of things that
you know that are seemingly impossible
need to happen
and it's and every film made is a minor
miracle but there's a way in which we
could be more proactive
so i um i would encourage people to
think along those lines and i'm here to
receive any funding if anybody wants to
donate right now
or read any screenplays or we well i
don't
that too i suppose
well i really couldn't agree with
oscar and janet moore i really think
you're going to have to assume that
you'll succeed and not really shoot
yourself down before someone else has
had a chance to try that and as chinese
americans i think we really need to
mentor each other we're going to have to
support each other
and you know speak up for each other i
think there should be a lot more
effort to you know publish our own
experiences
or
support
artistic works such as films or books
on the asian american or chinese
american experience because in the end
it is money that determines whether
these things get made and
the book publishing industry is very
similar to hollywood in that
in the end
the bottom line is what really counts
and executives always look to see how a
previous project has done
before deciding whether to fund another
project that has a similar theme so if
they get the sense that a community an
ethnic community
is not supporting its own projects they
are much less likely to gamble on a
similar topic and um like janet you know
i i i too hear a lot of complaints about
people saying well you know i don't like
novels that are are you know written
about chinese americans these days you
know like sometimes the characters are
presented as weak uh you know especially
chinese american men or the women are
seen as uh subservient and and the truth
is i think there are many things that
chinese americans can do in order to
shatter these stereotypes
first of all support the projects that
you feel give a more accurate
depiction of our community and secondly
if your children want to go into these
fields if they want to pursue their
dreams don't stand in their way because
we really need more voices in american
culture i think it's very dangerous not
to have a chinese more of a chinese
american presence and culture and i
think that
the these stereotypes can manifest
out in our society in ways that can harm
all of us i'll just give you a few
examples i do think that to this day
and it was worse in the 1950s the u.s is
still largely influenced by this
fu manchu image of the evil brilliant
chinese scientist
but the truth is chinese american
scientists have really done more i think
to help
american national defense than harm
they've helped build up silicon valley
um
you know they they have contributed
enormously to fields such as aerospace
we've got
you know nobel laureates but beyond that
we also have thousands of scientists who
have men made enormous contributions um
in just about every scientific
discipline there is
unfortunately
um
if if scientists in this country are
being um suspected and tarnished by
these stereotypes that's going to
interfere with their work and when i
think of the you know the alleged spying
cases that are now at los alamos i can't
help but think of the theme of my first
book thread of the silkworm which is the
story of what happened to a brilliant
chinese scientist
in the 1950s his name was dr tsiyan
hushen he was the father of
of
the chinese missile program and the
reason why he actually helped build up
the chinese missile program was because
when he was in the united states
as a professor at caltech and mit and as
you know a founder of the jet propulsion
laboratory he was falsely accused of
espionage and it eventually resulted in
his deportation
to the people's republic of china where
he then built up the infrastructure of
the ballistic missile program in china
and also contributed to the um i think
design of the the silkworm missile he
initiated that project but you see
in at that time there was rampant
chinese anti-chinese hysteria and it was
a time when chinese people could not
live in certain neighborhoods um they
they the the movie depictions of the
chinese uh were of the fu manchu variety
and he was a man who um did not you know
they never were able to find any
concrete evidence that he was a spy
although we'll never know um the full
details of this case but this the upshot
of the situation was that he was you
know arrested by ins uh authorities he
was kind of tried and convicted in the
american press
and things were just blown out of
proportion they said he was trying to
smuggle code books out of his
you know out of the country when the
code books turned out to be logarithmic
tables and uh you know and that set in
motion
events eventually led to his deportation
but um the the american media at the
time never
you know tried to correct that
perception and when it turned out that
he really didn't smuggle classified
documents out of this country they never
corrected it and in the end this
anti-chinese hysteria this
anti-communist hysteria came back to
haunt the united states because we
really lost one of uh the most brilliant
scientists in this country and
the country that was then uh that you
know the united states was very
concerned about the people's republic of
china gained one so i think that that's
why
we may look at the arts as something as
as esoteric and it's not really affects
our life but it actually does affect all
of us because it shapes public
perception of our community and that
eventually is going to translate into
direct action
well that's a perfect segue to david you
know the question of
uh
well this larger question in the first
place that we started with with the
responsibilities and the ways that we
can make those responsibilities concrete
by building
bridges within the community and between
this community and others but in
particular i'd like to i'm curious to
hear you respond to
this historical allegory that iris talks
about about the way that this one
individual chinese scientist had been
treated in the past in the midst of a
lot of uh hysteria
about the influence of china and by
extension of chinese americans and i'm
wondering whether
in your field which is broadly speaking
the sciences but is still so
far afield from all that's going on in
los alamos and the rest whether you're
feeling those kinds of ripple effects
the sense of uh politicization of the
kind of work you do and the kind of work
that others like in your position do
well there's no question i feel the
effect of the the most recent
allegations
first of all i'm a chinese-american
myself
i also came from taiwan
i don't work with classified material i
work with the deadly virus
but but
more importantly i actually have a
number of colleagues
who are from mainland china and
they are
greatly impacted by the recent events
they were impacted some years ago when
when there were accusations that many
chinese
students spied for china and that was
not taken very well by the group and and
this
uh is a even more serious uh charge
and and it's it's clear
that it
affects morale
uh they they are here contributing
to american science and for many years
for decades american science is largely
driven by the talent that flow from
other countries there was a period where
there was a great flow from from europe
and of course uh in past several decades
there's been a tremendous flow from asia
and particularly from china
and and america it's safe to say
american science would not be in its
present form without lots of and lots of
foreign talent
and as iris just pointed out
the the contributions greatly outweigh
any uh
espionage uh event
should that be real
and and this need to be portrayed uh to
the public and it never uh does
and so
and as i
just to extend a little bit as i think
about how to carry
our own work
to to international sites and
particularly in china
some of my colleagues actually ask
whether we will be accused
of
selling american science to to foreign
country for example we're working hard
trying to develop a vaccine that might
protect against the most prevalent
viruses that are now circulating in
china india and south africa
and
uh
being the the leader of the team and
being a chinese american i always
thought well perhaps it would be easiest
to conduct such a trial in china
do a collaboration get get it into early
testing in southern china with the
epidemic is
would we face to a lesser extent some of
these accusations of taking
u.s
uh dollars
research funded by u.s dollars and and
benefiting quote the chinese population
luckily for biomedical sciences the the
view is is much more liberal and then
what it whatever is good uh
for
for if you expression is should be good
for for humanity and then
but there's no question that that the
recent events are terrible for our
community
well this um i think in many ways brings
us full circle i want to leave the
balance of our time the 30 minutes or so
that we have left to take a lot of
questions but i just want to tie
together
a little bit what's been said because i
think um
you know what we're left with and what
we've heard a lot from this panel today
are these two trends which
coexist and run in many ways parallel to
one another intertwined with one another
and one is certainly a trend toward more
opportunity
more access more involvement
and more participation
but perhaps not unrelated to that rise
in participation and involvement and
influence
again is the trend and perhaps it's to a
lesser degree but the trend in the sense
that there are still many in this
country
who suspect
the loyalties of chinese americans or
asian americans who question or who come
again as i said at the outset to a room
like this with a presumption of
foreignness with a presumption that
asian americans or chinese americans are
foreign until proven otherwise uh to me
the benefit of the work that the people
on this panel are doing and the benefit
of the work that the committee of 100 is
doing
uh is by word and deed to begin to rebut
that presumption
and to begin to shift the presumption so
that people come into a room like this
into an environment like this
and really understand
that the contributions that people of
chinese descent are making and the
potential
that people of chinese descent have in
this country are something to be
reckoned with and it pauses that it's
one thing
to take a look at what's going on out
there
and point out the flaws
the problems in opportunity the problems
and stereotyping but what is incumbent
upon all of us uh because we have the
the means and the wherewithal to speak
uh is to speak
is to get our voices out there
and with that i would really welcome
some comments or questions from this
audience to all of our panelists
yes
sir
i just want to echo something
iris said
you know
about two weeks ago you know our
committee 100 was invited by the white
house to have a session with them
end of the session
the john podesta the chief of staff
asked us to
go dig up some chinese contributions
especially in the area of defense work
and iris you'll be happy to hear that
that we had a good missile builders
in chencherson
but i also have found that in the mid
80s
70
of our tactical missiles was managed by
a brilliant chinese engineer
in los angeles and his name happened to
be taiwan so of course he's retired now
and i just want to bring to the
attention that we have
good chinese-american engineering
engineers and scientists work in the
area of weapon trees
i i can't agree more i mean that really
the story of the brain drain of
technical talent from many different
countries to this country i think
is one of the untold greatest untold
stories the last half century and we
really have to recognize the
contributions
of not just chinese american scientists
and people from other you know from
china but but scientists from other
foreign countries and that the if if
if there is a prevailing sense in our
country that all foreign
born scientists are going to fall under
suspicion that would be devastating for
our country
and that's why i think we just have to
be
uh very careful you know i i think um
nobody in the committee of 100 would
endorse spying you know in any way shape
or form the question of course is um are
foreign-born scientists being treated
differently when they are accused of
spying than people who are caucasian or
who are who were born in this country so
i just think that
that
if people in this country have a better
sense of what the contributions of these
scientists have been then i think that
would really dispel a lot of the
suspicion which is why again i think you
know as david said we really have to
speak out and and i really do encourage
you know people who feel that they've
made an important scientific
contribution you should contact me via
my publisher because i think i need to
know about it for my third book and so
does you know the rest of the world
really it's it's it's really
a gigantic void in in the historical
literature
uh yes over there
um thanks for a wonderful discussion and
i also would like to thank you all for
sort of presenting a very hopeful tone
often at a lot of asian american
conferences they all they sort of have a
tendency to deteriorate into a bunch
sort of in
into these self-pitying sessions and and
so i'd like to thank you for sort of
presenting to today's asian americans
what what the possibilities are and i'd
like to thank mr oscar tang in
particular for sort of talking about
the fact that despite tremendous
difficulties like great strides have
been made
my question is that
when do you all think that chinese
americans actually can actually laugh at
themselves um i think one of the reasons
that the jerome d trip was so successful
was because precisely of his
self-deprecating sense of humor
and i think that for various other
minorities that sort of have made it for
instance you know if you look at the
jewish minority group or or various
others that there is an ability to laugh
at oneself and and i think it seems to
me that often for chinese americans
whenever someone says makes any sort of
a small comment about
you know the fact that you're chinese
american and whether they mean it as a
racist remark or not um
that we often sort of lack the ability
to just sort of take it lightly and and
and turn it into a joke and i wonder
whether you think that at any time in
the near future we can laugh at
ourselves with that kind of
self-confidence
it might be a good one for you
i laugh at myself all the time let's
laugh right now this is
if you've seen um wedding banquet by
angli
that's a very very funny movie about
chinese parents wanting their son to
find the ideal wife and all this
pressure for him to get married and of
course he's gay
i mean this is to me there were so many
levels of humor the difference between
mainland chinese and taiwan chinese i do
laugh at myself all the time i'm married
to somebody who's american he thinks a
lot of he would think there are funny
things about this and i think we have to
laugh at ourselves and i and that's what
i start out by saying is we by nature we
are funny people i didn't realize how
funny my parents were until i learned
chinese and i realized they are really
funny funny people now that we don't
have the language barrier to worry about
so much i can see just you know this is
i think we would just enjoy life more
number one i think people would be able
to enjoy us more number two and i think
it would indicate a sign that we
aren't acting like victims we're not
desperate anymore we've actually we're
at a completely different level of
assimilation now
and there are aspects to our existence
which is you know just are funny and
they
the cross cultural clashes i think um
i was just looking at eric's book
earlier today and there's some lovely
poignant moments which
which also can be seen as humorous about
what is it like to
not know
you know what we are i mean and
and i
am cons i mean i would like to do that
in film i think that's a a great way to
to show asians in a completely different
line and i think it can be done
right now as we speak i'm sorry i th
maybe i should clarify i didn't mean
laugh at ourselves in that way i think
we all
laugh at our parents we all laugh at our
friends i think i think that's a common
thing we do what i meant was that in
sort of a public way that that you know
for instance when someone sort of ish
when someone makes a certain comment
about chinese americans sometimes they
might not mean it in a derogatory way
but often a lot of civil rights groups
that represent chinese americans do take
it as in a derogatory way for instance
various cartoons that may not be meant
as racist um are often taken as races so
i'm just wondering from that kind of a
perspective i i don't mean sort of this
personal way of laughing at each other
or at our parents or anything like i
mean in in a sort of a public way though
the way we often
a lot particularly often the most
outspoken chinese americans who who who
always seem to say that they're standing
up for the rights of other chinese
americans
seem to be a lot seem to take
comments from other racial groups a lot
more seriously than those racial groups
sometimes take themselves so that's what
i meant i think i think i was trying to
address that by saying first
attitudinally we have to be laughing i
mean it's and not to be so touchy and
sensitive i personally feel that way and
if somebody
you know i may be in the minority here
in that sense but if somebody's doesn't
know any better and uses like blacks
will refer to themselves as [ __ ] now
we don't yet refer to ourselves as
chinks because it sounds still too you
know ugly
but at some point we may be able to let
it roll off our back because we know
we're not that anymore with all the
connotations that that word has and i
think it starts really with oneself
being being able to look around and and
maybe publicly we won't be so touchy
anymore i would think that would be a
positive sign
i think this is where
let me just add one point to that which
is uh this is where david henry hong
would i think would have had very
interesting things to say because these
dynamics
uh of language and humor uh are not just
unfolding in the abstract they unfold in
a societal context of uh power
and i think that you know you raise the
example for one thing let me say i'm all
for
laughing at ourselves
and i'm all for
not being
uh on a hair trigger when it comes to
comments or perceptions uh about uh us
as members of a minority group uh but
that said i think the the tensions that
we feel sometimes in these public
incidents
reflects the very
transitional phase that chinese
americans as a group are in so that when
you have something like
the cover of the national review
magazine of a couple of years ago
that had a stereotypical
caricature that uh
of uh
you know the first lady and the
president and the vice president and
with buck teeth slanted eyes and bamboo
hats uh on the one hand uh you certainly
want to be able to believe this is a
country where that can roll off our
backs uh and my first instinct was not
outrage when i saw that but upon seeing
how for many people it just it wasn't
humorous so much as it as it just kind
of confirmed a stereotype about asian
americans when you begin to see that
you begin to recognize that words jokes
images and the rest uh carry different
kind of moral and power baggage now that
doesn't mean that every single time
there is a caricature a joke or anything
like that
uh that those of us who are in the media
or in in the pub in public life
generally uh you know ought to uh
declare nuclear war there's got to be
some sense of degree and some sense of
perspective about this uh but i think
that it's just as important you know
because we are in this transitional
stage to make sure that those who don't
get whatever joke was intended know that
it's not particularly proper right uh to
make derogatory comments or pass off
derogatory images
of a group of people defined by their
race or ethnicity um other questions yes
little
alice
we've touched a little bit on politics
we don't have a politician and such on
the panel but my question is
just as asian americans were beginning
to be completely aware to recognize that
in order to make a difference you really
had to get into politics if you were
your hands dirty and they would get in
there you couldn't just
talk about it
and the momentum was there the campaign
fund scandal hit and suddenly there
seemed to be a real push
that asian americans were
withdrawing from
[Music]
[Music]
on whether in fact that's just our
perception out here or whether that's in
fact happening
[Music]
i think that's just an absolutely
important question
i think that in the immediate aftermath
of the
campaign finance scandals uh there
certainly was a chilling effect on a lot
of asian americans uh
and made a lot of asian americans who
were either already involved in politics
or thinking about getting more involved
in politics make them think twice
and i think that was a natural
consequence of
uh some of the things that were
circulating in the media and some of the
um you know as congressman salmon said
alluded to in his talk earlier today
this painting with broad brushes
and this inability to distinguish
uh between
uh asians on the one hand and asian
americans on the other and so i think in
the immediate aftermath there was this
uh
perhaps a bit of a chilling effect but
what i've seen to be honest with you and
i think it's borne out by a lot of the
people in this room
is that since then there continues to be
that momentum toward that generally
upward trend
uh i see it you know among people my own
contemporaries
there's a real shift i think in this
generation of people who are willing to
go into uh straight politics for one
thing working on campaigns getting
involved
working for politicians but also again
as i said earlier public life defined
more broadly whether it's you know as
oscar can speak to the realm of
philanthropy and civic life and
community service uh there's a fellow
named danny ceo who many of you probably
know of uh who is
one of america's foremost environmental
leaders he's in his early 20s
and he's asian-american and i think that
there are many more like him uh in
perhaps in uh you know less visible
roles but who are finding ways to get
involved in public life uh i think this
circles back to the whole question
of role models uh we're at a point right
now when you look at the political realm
where there's still you can count on one
or two hands
uh the number of elected asian american
officials nationwide um that everybody
in the country has heard something about
when i first got involved in political
work uh you know certainly figures like
uh bob matsui long time congressman from
california uh were just real
inspirations to me uh but this you know
as iris said as well when there's a
relative dearth of asian american role
models in that field you search out
other role models as well and i think
that's something that is absolutely
critical critical for asian americans to
remember as they try to move into public
life in the public square
which is that you can find your role
models and your mentors
anywhere you look
uh you can search out people who you
identify with perhaps not along the axis
of ethnicity but along the axis of
ideology or the axis of personal style
or the axis of whatever it may be that
there are a lot of ways in which we can
identify
with people
that aren't merely restricted to
identity as we've come to understand it
that's number one but number two i think
it's just absolutely critical as well
for this rising generation to recognize
that
alice as you said
these
scandals that may have these chilling
effects
that may slow the momentum
they may fade and they may pass but that
momentum doesn't rebuild of its own
accord it only rebuilds uh if individual
asian americans one by one by one by one
uh choose to get involved and it can be
on the smallest local level it can be on
the most
you know seemingly inconsequential uh
sorts of public affairs but it's just
developing those habits of political
association uh of being in public
and of making your voice heard that i
think are really uh crucial and i do
think that they are on the rise at least
within the younger cohort right now i
might add that sometimes it takes a
scandal like that to galvanize people
and say we will not let this be the
final word about asian americans
participation in politics and let's now
have all the more reason to be involved
and i think perhaps that is what's
happening hopefully it is
yes
thank you my name is ko lee i first like
to applaud the panelists and thank the
committee 100
for hosting this conference and as i
look around the room two things stand
out
there are
two generations the founders of the
committee 100 who made this possible and
also individuals who are the
beneficiaries and who are the the the
future of
our our community
a couple comments that were made in
terms of role models and in terms of
mentors
i happen to work for a large
pharmaceutical company
pfizer
and i'm very involved with our diversity
initiative our internal diversity
initiative and we started out as a
minority mentoring initiative
and
mentorship in corporate america is
by far i think the most critical aspect
for
for advancement and my plea is
as networking goes occurs at this forum
that the individuals who are in a
position to help
reach out
and mentor
the younger generation i'm referring to
the founders of the committee 100. my
plea is that to the action step is the
follow-up
of those who are looking for mentors
that if you have exchange cards in here
for those people who are in a position
to to help out uh please respond because
uh without that the energies that that
have that are so obvious in this room
will go to not it's very difficult once
we go back to our respective careers to
be lost and so when when emails or
letters or phone calls occur
it's just something else but if it comes
out of this
this conference
my hope is that we treasure it because
we all invested time in coming here and
a wonderful
experience tonight and i look forward
to a lot more productive work as a
result thank you
[Applause]
this concludes our program i want to
thank all the
those that made this possible
all the speakers all our sponsors the
committee members our volunteers and our
staff i hope you had a good meeting
[Music]
the chinaman's what
arch uh-huh
next a pair of commencement speeches
first you'll hear from surgeon general
was we're fighting to protect our homes
we're fighting to protect our families
an upcoming program on c-span 2's book
tv
next on history on book tv the chinese
in america
it's a new book from iris chang weaving
together the broad historical panorama
of chinese migration with case studies
of individual chinese immigrants
this talk from princeton university in
new jersey is an hour
i'm going to spend the first part of the
hour talking about the chinese in
america and narrative history and then
devote the rest of my time answering
questions from the audience
let me first tell you a little about
myself and why i wrote this book
for as long as i could remember i lived
in two separate realities as a
chinese-american
the reality of popular culture and the
reality of my own personal experience
popular culture told me that chinese
americans were hopelessly foreign exotic
and excludable
they were fu manchu charlie chan and
susie wong
they were those buck-toothed cartoon
figures with pigtails or lampshade hats
on saturday morning tv
they were those seven chinese brothers
from the popular children's book
who could withstand fire and suffocation
and swallowed the sea in one gulp they
were obviously not american and perhaps
not even human
but then there was the other reality i
knew
as the daughter of two professors in the
university town of champaign-urbana
illinois immigrant scholars from across
the globe from regions like china
india europe and the middle east would
converge on this little midwestern
community where they celebrated their
ethnicity
with campus-sponsored festivals and
parties while also working together to
research important intellectual topics
my high school was like a mini united
nations in its racial diversity
and many of my classmates came from or
later engaged in interracial marriage as
i would when i reached adulthood
so during the most formative years of my
life
i grew up with the perception that while
mass american entertainment might be
biased
in real life
people can cherish their cultural
heritage while also befriending each
other and marrying each other across
lines across color lines because that's
what i saw and experienced every day and
i believed as many people did that
anti-asian racism might one day become a
relic of the past
all throughout the 1980s the major news
media carried optimistic stories about
chinese americans winning nobel prizes
and flooding the best universities in
the country and acing the westinghouse
and national merit scholarship
competitions
the chinese were called the modern
minorities the model minorities moving
onward and upward at an incredible pace
but all of this would change by the late
1990s and for the very first time in my
life i saw the reality of popular
culture collide with the reality of my
personal experience which destroyed
lives in the process
the collapse of the soviet empire made
china the second greatest superpower and
hence a prime contender for the role of
america's new enemy a time magazine
cover story implied that a new cold war
with china was on the horizon
and a deeply flawed report released by
the special committee under congressman
christopher cox suggested that the prc
had been stealing nuclear secrets from
the u.s for decades
and the result was a major anti-chinese
backlash in the u.s
especially in the national laboratories
the most visible victim of this was wen
holy a taiwanese american scientist at
los alamos laboratory who was accused of
passing design secrets of the w88
warhead to mainland china
after he was fired without a hearing and
held in dreadful conditions in prison
the u.s had to admit later that it had
no evidence that we committed espionage
and also revealed the embarrassing fact
that the w88 technology china had could
not have come from los alamos
during the league controversy chinese
american scientists who had devoted
their lives to strengthening american
defense with their technological
research were being interrogated as if
they were spies for the prc and for many
people of my parents generation
this was entirely new and unexpected
previously the worst racist episodes
against the chinese seem to come from
mainly blue collar and poor areas such
as the vincent chin or jim lu cases
people who were killed in the streets by
whites after confrontations in a strip
club or pool hall
now we were seeing an attack by highly
sophisticated government agencies
against a highly sophisticated strata of
chinese american society
their scientists their engineers their
high-tech professionals
and for chinese intellectuals who had
always been supported by the us
government in scholarships and salaries
and research grants for those chinese
who had spent their professional lives
nurtured by our universities and
national laboratories this was a very
frightening development
and it would only get worse
the anti-chinese backlash climaxed in
april 2001 when a american navy spy
plane on a u.s surveillance mission
collided with the chinese fighter jet
over the south chinese sea
the chinese pilot was killed and the
chinese government detained 24 american
crew members of the spy plane after they
made an emergency landing in china's
hainan island
unfortunately after 11 days of tense
negotiation and a carefully worded
apology from the united states
the prc
did release the crew but not before the
chinese american population had endured
ugly and racist stereotyping
you should have heard the hatred that
came over the airwaves
talk show hosts wanted chinese employees
fired from the national laboratories or
expelled from the u.s or even imprisoned
as japanese americans were during world
war ii
in springfield illinois two radio djs
urged the boycott of all chinese
american restaurants and suggested that
all chinese americans be shipped out of
the country and even telephone people
with chinese last names to harass them
even newspaper editors indulged in
anti-chinese stereotypes during the spy
plane crisis
in april 2001
amy liang a chinese-american college
senior was interning at the azni
reporter which is a publication of the
american society of newspaper editors
the society organized national
convention in washington dc
and liang was assigned to photograph the
performance of a comedy troupe during
the opening reception
the troop put on a skit about u.s
chinese relations and i would like to
read verbatim liang's description of the
event
white males impersonated a chinese
official and his translator
the officials sported a black wig and
thick glasses and spoke fake chinese
ching ching chong chong the man shouted
as he gestured wildly what was
disturbing was not just the fact that
this was happening but that hundreds of
editors my future bosses were laughing i
felt myself swallowed by all the loud
laughter every time the chinese voice
became more jarring the editors would
laugh even harder despite feeling
humiliated i finished the job and turned
in my picture
the next morning i woke up crying
those are amy liang's words and the skit
merely reflected the popular mood of the
times a year 2001 gallup poll found that
more than 80 percent of americans viewed
the prc as dangerous
in another poll a national telephone
survey commissioned by the committee of
100 and the anti-defamation league found
that close to half of the people polled
thought that chinese americans uh
were
that passing were passing secrets to the
chinese government or that that they
might be doing it and that was the
problem almost the third believed that
chinese americans were more loyal to the
prc than to the u.s
but then something even more unexpected
happened
the terrorist attacks
of 9 11.
like other americans i watched with
horror the footage of the hijacked
planes crashing into the twin towers of
the world trade center
and then just as quickly as the
anti-chinese backlash had arrived
it vanished
suddenly middle eastern immigrants were
the new pariahs of american society
and so as i wrote the chinese in america
i tackled a number of provocative
questions that are central not only to
the chinese american experience but the
entire american immigrant experience
such as
how can an ethnic group that is embraced
by america and celebrated for its hard
work and achievement suddenly find
itself vilified
why does it happen
how frequently does this happen in
american society and how can we stop it
from happening again
when you read my book you'll see how the
united states a country that prides
itself as a bastion of fair play and
justice once shut the chinese out from
the gates of immigration and the law and
even turned a blind eye to the wholesale
slaughter
of chinese americans across the american
west for more than more than a century
ago
there's a perception out there that the
chinese in america started out poor and
downtrodden at the bottom of society
only to rise steadily to the top
but the reality is that the chinese like
other ethnic groups endured cycles of
acceptance and abuse wild swings between
xenophobia and tolerance and at certain
times in history they were praised and
celebrated as honorary whites while at
other times they were loathed and even
killed their fate oscillated with
factors beyond their control such as
economic and political conditions and
the state of american diplomatic
relations with china
if i may summarize these cycles briefly
we could look at the history of the
chinese in america as the story of three
major immigrant waves of the last 150
years
each of which experienced great extremes
of success and mistreatment
the first wave of chinese mostly men
came in the mid-19th century the
majority to join the california gold
rush although others migrated directly
from other regions and two other regions
they were warmly welcomed when they
first arrived because because the u.s
needed their labor especially during the
civil war
and as they filled this labor shortage
the chinese made huge unheralded
contributions to this country such as
building the transcontinental railroad
transforming the western frontier into
land for agriculture and they also
labored in factories and canneries
during the american industrial
revolution
but the chinese also faced a backlash
especially in california
white americans began to view them as a
problem as the chinese copulation grew
in particular during the economic
depression of the 1870s when white
workers found it hard to compete
effectively with chinese capitalists and
wage earners
in desperation white workers organized
among themselves politically against
chinese immigrants
and the ethnic chinese soon found
themselves demonized in the media the
subject of racist state legislation and
also forced to pay more taxes and
license fees than any other group in
california while also not being
permitted to vote or use many government
services that were sustained by their
taxes
they could not testify against whites or
work for a public corporation and their
children were the only group to be
denied a state-funded education
and matters would only grow worse when
the chinese
when the chinese actually found
themselves demonized all the more as
california became a crucial swing state
during presidential elections political
parties adopted anti-chinese platforms
to court california
in washington
officials found it convenient to blame
the nation's ills on the chinese rather
than to have the public scrutinize their
own corruption and their own acceptance
of bribes and their collusion with big
industry which was rampant at the time
and so in 1882 congress passed the
chinese exclusion act which would shut
the gates of immigration to chinese
labor for the next 60 years
other laws passed over the next few
decades would lock the chinese out of
the country when they were visiting
china even if they had property and
families in the u.s they would force
them to register with the government for
residential certificates
and even deprive them of the protection
of the courts and bail in hiabus corpus
cases and threaten even the privileges
associated with birthright citizenship
anti-chinese riots and massacres would
also drive many of the chinese out of
small towns and cities across the
american west and thousands left for
china never to return
the remaining chinese faced government
harassment and repeated assaults against
their civil liberties such as arrests in
the middle of the night interrogation by
immigration authorities demands for
bribes by corrupt officials
and threats of deportation to china and
as they would discover all it would take
was one crime by one chinese man to put
the entire chinese population under
siege when a young white girl named
elsie siegel was apparently murdered by
her chinese boyfriend in new york city
the police forbade any chinese person to
leave the city without permission and
across the country the chinese were
arrested indiscriminately when they
stepped off trains or tried to buy
steamship tickets
during their search for the killer the
police in providence rhode island even
forced all chinese restaurants to remove
the drapes from every room stall and
booth so the interior could be viewed
from the outside at all times
this case showed just how quickly the
constitutional rights of the chinese
could be suspended in an instant during
a time of government declared emergency
and the cycle of acceptance and abuse
would be repeated for the chinese in the
20th century during the second major
wave of their immigration
the doors to chinese immigration opened
up again after the repeal of the
exclusion laws following the japanese
attack on pearl harbor which led people
in the u.s to see the chinese and by
extension the chinese americans as the
good guys during the sino-american
wartime reliance
also new legislation during the 1960s
swept away the racist immigration quotas
against asian countries
now the second wave consisted largely of
students and highly educated
professionals representing one of the
greatest brain drain waves of chinese
immigrant talent to the united states
many were intellectuals capitalists or
bureaucrats who had held prominent
positions in the deposed nationalist
regime and who were forced to leave
after or shortly before the communist
takeover of 1949.
a few of these people went directly to
the united states immediately during the
communist revolution but many more fled
to hong kong or taiwan before later
migrating to america
to study or to start new careers there
some were college students or graduate
students who during the chinese civil
war were stranded in the u.s without a
country to return to and they decided to
stay
but large-scale immigration from
mainland china itself
seized when the prc isolated itself from
the world community during the mao
zedong years
and just like this first wave the second
wave was warmly welcomed at first
the chinese came at a time when the
united states
needed and actively sought immigrant
brain power as they entered the arms
race against the soviet union
the u.s federal government poured
billions of dollars into research into
our national laboratories and
universities
especially after the russian launch of
sputnik made americans believe they were
lagging behind in science and technology
and so these new chinese
entered our universities are
corporations on our defense laboratories
designing some of america's earliest
rockets
developing powerful drugs and medicines
and fueling the high-tech and scientific
revolution
in silicon valley and elsewhere their
contributions would help establish and
maintain u.s supremacy in the
information age and some became
extraordinarily successful as you know
as nobel laureates and ceos and pioneers
in their fields
but always it wasn't always smooth
sailing for this group
when the korean war broke out and when
american troops clashed with communist
chinese forces and when reports surfaced
of white soldiers being slaughtered
imprisoned or tortured in pow camps
the chinese america in america were
quickly considered the bad guys as the
japanese americans had been a few years
earlier and reports began to surface of
ethnic chinese being physically attacked
and their property vandalized and the
chinese americans who were suspected of
being communist sympathizers found their
mail opened and their phone lines tapped
and their movements shadowed in the
streets by government agents
the us government even considered
proposals to incarcerate the chinese in
concentration camps and even allocated
money to set up detention center centers
one person whose career in the us was
destroyed by the anti-chinese hysteria
was sian hushen a visionary caltech
professor of aeronautics and the subject
of my first book thread of the silkworm
during world war ii dr tsan had worked
on secret military projects resulting in
the production of some of america's
first military missiles and he was also
one of the founders of the jet
propulsion laboratory in pasadena
but during the mccarthy years
he was falsely accused of being a
communist and possibly a spy mainly
because some of his friends at caltech
had belonged to a secret socialist club
during the
1930s and unfortunately for cn this
accusation came
when the united states was entering one
of its most paranoid eras in history
china had fallen to the communists the
russians had successfully detonated
their first
nuclear bomb and the evidence suggested
that there was a british and american
spy ring that had helped pass some of
the atomic secrets to the russians
and the u.s government and the public
began to suspect that the whole country
was infested with spies
and so after five years of investigation
and virtual house arrest in pasadena
during which time the us government did
not find one scrap of real evidence that
cn was either a spy or a communist
doctor tsan was deported to china
against his will
as part of a secret government swap
between the prc and the us for american
pilots shot down by the people's
republic during the korean war
and ironically after being forced to
return to china xian revolutionized the
chinese ballistic missile program and
also helped initiate the design of the
silkworm missile which was used against
the american armed forces during the
first persian gulf war so all of this
suggests to me that many of these
obsessive measures to promote security
tend to produce the opposite effect
history would repeat itself once again
during the third wave of chinese
immigration which occurred after the u.s
resumed diplomatic relations with the
prc
business boomed in china and tens of
thousands of chinese scholars
as well as people from all social
economic classes came to the united
states
however as i discussed before the
disintegration of the soviet empire and
the rise of china as the world's second
major superpower
raised concerns among some groups that
china would soon rival the united states
and it's interesting to note that during
this time new legislation was passed to
make it very difficult for many chinese
immigrants and immigrants of other races
to effectively compete with
american-born citizens
the immigration act of
1990 introduced the h-1b visa program
for highly educated and skilled
immigrant workers but they restricted
the time that such visa holders could
work in the u.s to a maximum of six
years
of course critics of this program called
it white-collar servitude or high-tech
coulism because a disproportionate
number of these h-1b visa holders were
chinese and as the 1990s progressed the
u.s government feared that ethnic
chinese scientists would pass military
secrets to the prc as seen in the wenhoe
li case
since the past is prologue we have to
look to history to understand how and
why the chinese and other groups
face these cycles of persecution and and
oso acceptance
i'd like to share with you some of my
theories and conclusions
my research suggests to me that the real
driving forces behind racism
is not something that depends merely on
physical or cultural differences
the appearance of the chinese the shape
of their eyes the darkness of their skin
their black hair did not offend most
white people or bring out their most
xenophobic impulses until certain
conditions
came into play and i think these
conditions usually require
a political or economic crisis
the
exclusion act had emerged out of the
depression of the 1870s the anti-chinese
witch hunts of the mccarthy years came
after mainland china turned communists
and the most recent backlash against the
chinese in the 1990s grew out of u.s
concerns that the chinese would feel the
massive power void left by the russians
i think that the theme of crisis being
linked to
abuse and violence can also be found in
my second book the rape of nanking which
describes the mass rape and torture and
murder of hundreds of thousands of
chinese civilians by japanese imperial
forces in the capital of china in 1937
as i tried to understand the root cause
behind these atrocities i studied other
acts of genocide across world history
such as the armenian massacre committed
by the turks and the jewish holocaust by
the germans
and these horrific acts all had certain
elements which preceded them
an economic depression the rise of
dictatorships and a racial scapegoat
often in order to consolidate their
power politicians will search for a
common enemy as the means to unite the
people and a certain minority group at
home or a perceived enemy overseas will
be scapegoated and sacrificed
and in these situations
the powerful can exploit racism as a
tool of social control to preserve the
position of existing elites and also to
hamper serious uh debate and analysis
and serve as a smoke screen to obscure
some of the larger and more deeper
social problems in that in that society
and it's very easy to see how this could
happen when people's jobs are at stake
when they feel threatened
they're often willing to give up some of
their personal freedom for greater
protection from the government
but as history has revealed time and
time again
the choice to trade liberty for security
is usually the most dangerous choice of
all
according to the research of r.j rummel
for example a world expert on genocide
it's not the genetic makeup of a
particular people nor a particular
religion nationality or political
philosophy that causes people to kill
but sheer absolute unchecked power in
other words the more concentrated the
power in the hands of an elite the more
likely that elite regardless of its race
or culture or any other factor
will commit human rights abuses both at
home and abroad
and initiate war with their neighbors
and according to the empirical data on
the subject
dictatorships and totalitarian regimes
are just by nature more likely to wage
war on other countries and torture their
own citizens at home
than democratic societies because
absolute power will give people the
ability to act instantaneously on those
dark impulses that lie within us all and
the solution
according to rommel is to diffuse power
through education and through democracy
grassroots political activism will hold
leaders accountable for their actions
and education and public access to
government or information will enable
people to make informed decisions about
their elected officials
i think democracy needs to be championed
not as some abstract ideal but as an
actual preventative measure against
atrocity
and what i found in my research was that
the chinese in america were very active
participants in this process of
democracy and contrary to popular belief
and stereotypes they were never passive
victims of injustice
what isn't commonly discussed in history
textbooks is that they fought back time
and again
using the tactics of martin luther king
and gandhi even before they had existed
passive resistance non-violent protests
petitions boycotts and court hearings
there was amazingly little violence that
you would expect from a group that
experienced such legal discrimination
and even systematic slaughter in some
regions the chinese went to the law they
used the law and they fought for their
rights
for example
during the 19th century
during the construction of the
transcontinental railroad the chinese
peacefully organized a labor strike
against the central pacific demanding
higher wages and fewer hours and an end
to the whippings that they endured by
white foreign and they did succeed in
winning a few concessions
in the american south where post-civil
war plantation workers
excuse me plantation owners had toyed
with the idea of replacing black slavery
with chinese labor the chinese had hired
interpreters to negotiate their
contracts and sued employers if they
violated them they also sued white
schools in california and elsewhere that
refused to admit their children they
helped organize boycotts in china of
american products
to demand better treatment of chinese
immigrants by american authorities
during the exclusion era and they also
pulled together their resources to hire
some of the best white lawyers and
lobbyists of the day to overturn some of
the anti-chinese laws
it was the struggle that would help lay
down the foundation
of civil rights law to the benefit of
human rights activists several decades
later for example yiquo versus hopkins
set the standard for equal protection
before the law that any law applied in a
discriminatory manner whether to u.s
citizens or foreign aliens is
unconstitutional
wong kim mark vs u.s upheld the
principle of birthright citizenship
which would prevent american-born
non-white people
from being stripped of their citizenship
and relegated into a permanent foreign
underclass
many anti-chinese laws disappeared from
the books after world war ii but the
chinese americans remain public uh
publicly and politically active for
example during the civil rights movement
of the 1960s chinese-american students
staged sit-ins and demonstrations that
forced universities like san francisco
state and berkeley to establish ethnic
studies departments
and since the 1980s chinese americans
have held huge rallies
and raised legal funds to fight hate
crimes such as the brutal murders of
vincent shin and jim liu
chinese scientists also organized a
successful boycott of the national
laboratories after the u.s government
engaged in illegal racial profiling
tactics in the wenhoe li case
many of the legal rights and protections
that we americans take for granted today
are the direct result of countless
lawsuits filed by the
early chinese in the united states
but i'm afraid that the gains of a
century and a half of activism
may be wiped out in a very short period
of time
the usa patriot act of 2001 and its
sequel the proposed domestic security
enhancement act of 2003
threatens to destroy many of these
hard-won american rights such as our
right to habeas corpus hearings
or even our right to retain our u.s
citizenship
today
officials are also evoking some of the
most shameful legislation of the past to
justify present policies in the name of
security
a few months ago representative howard
coble
head of homeland security subcommittee
shocked the asian american community by
defending the imprisonment of japanese
americans in the 1940s
he said and i'll quote him
some probably were intent on doing harm
to us
just as some of these arab americans are
probably intent on doing harm to us
as you know the middle eastern ethnic
community has suffered great persecution
since 9 11
in a manner reminiscent of the
persecution of the chinese american
community during the mccarthy era and
the exclusion period people have been
ordered off airplanes harassed and
attacked in the streets there have been
detentions without court hearings and
deportations and according to some of
the human rights attorneys that i know
in the bay area who are representing the
needs of that community
some families are actually fleeing from
the united states as refugees into
canada
this should not and cannot continue you
have to leave options open for
immigrants you cannot cut them off from
the law and when you do that you're
asking for outrage and mayhem and the
flight of the best immigrant talent from
this country
people need to recognize this not as an
ethnic issue but as a human rights issue
the dangers of racial profiling is that
the government can use a divide and
conquer strategy suspending the rights
of various groups one at a time until
everyone suffers in the end
as long as any group is being
scapegoated in america
merely on the basis of its cultural
heritage none of us are safe
the book i have just written
may be considered an ethnic book but it
does contain universal themes of human
nature that transcend ethnicity we
cannot leave the business very difficult
business of democracy into the hands of
just our elected officials governments
will not relinquish or share power until
people force them to
and significant social change rarely
occurs from the top down rarely it
percolates rather it does percolate from
the bottom up so groups of all different
races need to form coalitions with each
other and reach out to each other
not turn within themselves
to be effective champions of democracy
all of us have to be more aggressive and
proactive in crossing class and color
lines it means talking to our elected
officials
educating them about our lives and
holding them accountable for their
actions
it means writing op-eds and going to
public protests when needed it means
networking with a wide circle of people
ranging from the victims to even the
perpetrators of hate crimes to
understand the causes for their behavior
i think sometimes the most effective
ways to resolve conflicts or just to
prevent them from happening in the first
place is to simply listen to other
people and acknowledge their point of
view which are the first and very
necessary steps required to start a
dialogue
since we're in all of this together as
americans i want my book to be viewed
not simply as an ethnic chinese story
but as a quintessential american one
my personal identity as a chinese
american derives its force from my
rights and duties and obligations as an
american citizens
and the struggle to uphold american
democracy
the struggle to protect human rights and
civil liberties of all americans not
just chinese americans
is an ongoing struggle for all of us
and our descendants and their
descendants rather than a job that's
already finished and done so if there's
just one message i'd like to get across
to my readers it's that democracy is not
and was never a guarantee it is still
very much a young and fragile experiment
thank you so much for your time
[Applause]
[Music]
i'd be happy to take any questions from
the floor at this time
yes
thanks yeah your very interesting talk
dealt mainly with the relationship
between chinese americans and the
american state on the one hand and
chinese americans and the majority
population in the united states the
white population but of course the
united states
also has very significant ethnic
minorities apart from chinese americans
and particularly african-americans and
hispanic americans and i was wondering
whether you might want to say a few
words about the relationship between the
chinese-american community
and the other minorities that exist in
the united states
well
it's a relationship that has evolved
over time for decades i would say that
during the
civil rights movement
chinese americans particularly in places
like the san francisco bay area
worked with
other ethnic groups
to champion uh their human rights and
then their civil liberties and um
i would there was an alliance actually
between um some
organizations uh in these the bay area
with the black panthers and also in
universities such as san francisco state
and berkeley as i mentioned before there
was
an organization by the name of the third
world liberation front
and
that was a coalition of
of asian americans hispanic americans
native american indians and
african-americans i think as well as
other groups really to push for
ethnic studies departments
and today
we find
also i would say
some of these cross-cultural
efforts often to promote civil liberties
so right now that
there is a great deal of concern i think
after 9 11 of the possibility that
immigrants can be detained without court
hearings in prison and japanese
americans have actually been extremely
active in that cause
helping middle eastern
immigrant human rights activists because
it's experience they deeply understand
uh just a quick question um i was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about some of the differences between
the book that you've just written and
some of the earlier scholarship on
chinese immigration to the u.s because i
think there have been a lot of
books who've covered the experience
thoroughly and also focused on various
aspects and different periods of time in
the last 150 years and maybe you could
speak about whether there's new research
or a new type of angle that you've taken
or um what is it that uh inspired you to
write write
essentially a new book on chinese
immigration to the u.s
there have certainly been pioneering
books on the history of chinese of the
chinese in america
and i think some of the uh
some of the path-breaking books came out
in the 1980s what i think distinguishes
this book from some of the others is
merely that it actually continues the
story from the 1980s to the present it
also um
has a pattern of describing some of the
conditions in china that led to the
immigration to the united states and
then often
then bringing the narrative back to
china to just and then and following the
chinese as they come to this country and
following this their the experience of
their descendants so the um structure
which follows the three great waves i
think is um different from how a lot of
other
authors have framed their research
also
it's
it uses a narrative style and approach
which i think
you know gives the person a sense that
they are undergoing a journey with
chinese americans across american
history um
i would also say that this book tackles
many of the controversial subjects that
have emerged in just the last few years
such as the the wen holi
case and and also
many allegations of discrimination
from chinese americans in the national
laboratories
as well as also chinese
american asian american students that
are leading universities who claim that
they have often faced
um
discriminatory quotas and policies to
keep their numbers down so
all of these can be found in
all these subjects can be found
discussed at length in my book
if you'll excuse me i'm gonna get some
water
um in comparison to some other
minorities in america especially african
americans
asian americans are considered
politically apathetic i was wondering if
a you think that is true and b what are
the reasons you think for this political
apathy
well
i think what distinguishes my book from
others is that i don't really believe
the chinese have been politically
apathetic i think that there's a
perception out there but when i
uh delved into the subject i found that
um
the the the
the material out there really surprised
me that
the chinese were
very active often writing
letters to politicians
lobbying for their causes um
protesting the streets and and um
and and there was this whole body of
litigation that
you can find you know in places like the
national archives which is very much
part of our legal history and set down
the foundation of civil rights law so um
there's a perception out there but i
don't think it's it's true what i think
is is interesting is that many of these
efforts have not been noticed
well i want to thank you for your talk i
think the idea that some of the new laws
are actually impacting some of the
rights that chinese americans fought for
100 years ago is
is really great i think that's a that's
a great observation um
in this sort of scholarship now about
the sort of religiousness of the chinese
in the 19th century um
there's sort of this unanswered question
running through the scholarship and i
was wondering what you found and sort of
what you thought about it which is what
the chinese plaintiffs and some of the
sort of um
money was supporting the cases thought
they were doing we have very few
first-person accounts right in those
gnar cases actually it's very hard to
figure out what people thought they were
doing when they were bringing cases like
yakuo for example actually what the what
the sort of laundry guild thought they
were doing those minutes haven't come
out so i was interested in in in your in
your research what you found in terms of
first person understandings of what some
of those legal challenges were about for
them
again some of this information as you
said is very difficult to come by
and there's often much more that you'll
find in the public record than often the
um the diaries or maybe minutes as you
pointed out or or secret thoughts of
many of the chinese live that and that's
the challenge that i think all
historians face and
and it gets excruciatingly difficult
often to find some of this information
as you move further back in time uh for
obvious reasons and um
and you'll you'll see even just with
information
generated just a few decades ago
sometimes that's hard to locate too in
china especially after the cultural
revolution when there were bond fires of
personal papers
so um but here and there you'll find
personal accounts often in archives and
in personal collections and and more
diaries have been coming to light in
just recent years
one thing that one can observe in the
u.s among the chinese community here is
um
certain kind of racism among chinese
towards um black america you know
african americans and other kinds of
colored people and this is the issue
that seldom that one can really observe
and you know you you notice that kind of
thing but it really seldom transpires in
um
in academic and popular discourses um
and i was wondering the kind of efforts
you try to promote in terms of um
solidarities among
ethnic immigrants in the us the issue of
racism
of colored people against other kinds of
colored people should be also be erased
and there should also be the kind of
education
um
of ourselves um against
our own racism
in a way
um i couldn't agree with you more i do
think that all of these
racial tensions need to be addressed and
if there's one thing i've discovered in
the course of my research is that no one
particular racial group is either you
know
immune from being the victims of or
persecutors
of other of groups so um so i think it's
important to frame a lot of these issues
in terms of human rights and to really
look at some of the universalist causes
for for these um these kinds of tensions
and
racial uh impulses um
i personally believe that often
what often brings the xenophobic
impulses in all of us right up to the
surface are
you know economic and political crises
and that's it that's usually necessary i
think for for um
the um the hatred to explode and when
when
in the absence of a lot of these crises
when there's a great deal of opportunity
people are often much more tolerant so i
think we just have to be um aware of
these these um forces out there that
that um
are something right be under the surface
for these racial atrocities
hi
you spoke a lot about the obligation of
the chinese-american community to fight
for their rights and not let the
victories of the past 150 years fade
however when other minority groups do
this they're often criticized for
distinguishing themselves from the
majority and by distinguishing
themselves undermining their
assimilation and their tolerance efforts
so where do you think the
chinese-american community should draw
the line between assimilation and still
trying to fight for their rights and
maintain the victories that they've had
over the past
century let me see if i understand your
question you're saying that how do you
maybe embrace your heritage
and also
assimilate and win acceptance from the
mainstream population in part there are
a lot of minority groups that are
criticized for constantly fighting for
their rights but in doing so distinguish
themselves as completely separate from
americans as purely minority groups and
in doing so undermine efforts for the
majority to accept them as americans and
so where do you think that the
chinese-american community should draw
that line well i think it's important
i don't think they have to see these
i don't think they have to see an
embrace of their cultural heritage and
also
their
efforts to reach out to
other groups as is mutually you know
exclusive i think you could do both um
there's um
actually as i've mentioned earlier in my
speech
i pretty much saw this happening in my
own community where people would have
festivals often to um to celebrate their
ethnic traditions but yet they were
working together um
on research projects you know with
people of different races so it never
seemed to me that
doing one or the other would would um
would you know were contradictory so i
would think that the important thing is
to
to remain tolerant that you know while
you
you know you have
uh forms to discuss these issues with
members of your own minority group that
you also make efforts constantly to
reach out to other groups
regardless of race and and really see
these um
problems as
human rights issues and not not just
issues that are specific to a particular
ethnic group
hi um i'm going to expand on the
previous question um
do you think that uh
the asian american associations across
the country uh
maybe reacted too
aggressively um
a year ago
during the abercrombie fitch incident
that happened when they featured the
offensive shirts the the line of shirts
that appeared in in their stores
there was a pretty aggressive reaction
from many especially student
associations across the country were
there complaints then that the um that
the reaction was too aggressive i
remember seeing a lot of emails on the
subject or do you feel that um
i'm just kind of curious was there was
this later the subject of great
discussion afterwards i'm just expanding
on the previous question about uh where
do you put the line between um your
cultural heritage and then assimilation
for example
if
i mean abercrombie has put shirts
i think
making fun of various european
nationalities they never
i don't know of any like irish people
complaining
about
irish you know humor and portraying
irish people and jokes
but uh at the same time
asian people seem to be more offended so
does that mean that they still think
that they are not assimilated
into the country that
i think that maybe it's um
it came from probably years of
seeing all of the stereotypes and maybe
not speaking out and finally there was
there has been a trend of of saying
enough is enough i mean i think that
people were so offended by these was
these the shirts with the saying no you
know two two wong's don't make a white
or yeah i i i think that if if an ethnic
group is particularly upset and offended
by
uh some of these jokes
it's important to speak out because you
have to be honest to how you feel and um
it just could be that
see
if you mentioned that they made made
jokes of other ethnic groups
that um
it
it didn't really draw probably it didn't
evoke as much um
response if because many many um
caucasian americans probably do not see
themselves
as um you know
foreigners but or or or pretty much
linked to a foreign culture as much as
um i think a lot of chinese are
stereotyped as still being perpetual
foreigners and i think that these shirts
were pretty much a reaction to the
stereotypes that had been building up in
the media so i think it was it was
definitely important for the chinese
american community or asian americans
to um
to articulate their concerns because
there had been already at that time so
much hostility in the media especially
after you know after the the wen hali
case so um it was important to bring
this to the surface and i so i actually
believe it was uh it was an important
thing to do
you see i think that an ethnic group
that is concerned
has to speak out you know it's it it
shouldn't squelch its voices just
because it's afraid of offending the
mainstream
uh hi i've got a question
sort of linked
to what you mentioned to be the driving
force of racism in that it's not just
skin color
and culture but
it's sort of like racist tendencies in a
sense what you're mentioning it sounded
like racist tendencies were always there
but they're sort of
kept under during good political or
economic times and it's only when you
have a crisis that there's suddenly an
eruption and doesn't seem like how many
barriers or safeguards you put in place
but
you'll find that even in 2001
you still have you still have kind of a
really serious backlash against a
particular ethnic
community of americans
and
i was wondering you mentioned that uh
there was r.j rummel who sort of had
sort of a solution about uh the
unbalance of power unchecked power um
you sort of need to diffuse it through
with education but i guess i was
wondering
what do you think sort of the if there
is some sort of a solution uh to the
problem of as soon as everybody gets
xenophobic then suddenly all the racist
tendencies come back and we're allowed
to intern anybody we want and we're
allowed to discriminate as much as we
can i mean well
what's i mean what can we what can we do
it seems like history has shown that
even throughout the 20th century the
chinese still have been facing the
problems is there some sort of
fundamental change in uh in
legal or political agencies or economic
agencies that
that
that asian american organizations the
whole country should be pushing for i'm
just sort of wondering i think
individually everyone has to speak out
i'm not sure that um
to have like a a gov some kind of
government sponsored initiative would be
some i mean would be enough i actually i
think that everyone has to do what they
can
to um address these needs and i i'm i'm
a big proponent of grassroots activism i
just don't think that a lot of these
problems can be solved um
by just a handful of of elected
officials um
it has there has to be a nationwide
effort among people to
to stay on top of what's happening and
and that requires an educated populace
if you if you don't have an educated
populace the people are going to
be
very vulnerable to the stereotypes that
they they will not question them and
when they emerge they'll think that
whatever is being purveyed in the media
is is correct and i think that
there has to be an ongoing effort among
every individual
to
to gain access to information government
information which already is a struggle
in itself and then be able to
to to judge it and evaluate it and act
upon it that that requires
um that requires education it also
requires a real civic commitment on the
part of all americans i mean too often i
hear people say well this is
all what's happening in the world today
it's all too big for me i
i i'm just a little guy i i there's
nothing i can do and i'm just gonna
leave it up to whoever's in charge that
kind of mindset and impulse is
extraordinarily dangerous
because it's going to only encourage
that concentration of power in the hands
of elite that we were just talking about
with rj rumble's research
and so um
i think the the solution is you're going
to have to have watchdog groups
constantly you know monitoring the
activities of those who are in power
well c-span is here today i would say
that for example just the
the existence of an organ program like
c-span which gives us direct access to
some of these government activities
without the filtering um
uh you know medium of of the the
networks is an extremely valuable
contribution to our society
but you know it also requires like you
know
sending off freedom of immigration act
requests to um the government every time
some something develops you want to find
out where's the evidence what what
what's the cause of this and what we're
finding now is um a lot of information
that was once
uh declassified the national archives
are now being reclassified
um
the records of the the um the reagan
administration now are not easily
they're not open to the public there are
many disturbing trends that are shutting
down access to the public's right to get
information and that all
is going to hurt
our ability to sustain a healthy
democracy and
the only way to fight it is for every
individual
to
to speak out when when they see
something that doesn't seem to be proper
i mean that could in every individual
has individual talents
uh for some people it means
meeting with our elected officials and
having dialogues with them for other
people it could mean protesting in the
streets peaceful protests uh for others
it could be writing books writing op-eds
um or or speaking uh you know on the
radio uh
everyone has their own unique talents
but i am a firm believer of grassroots
activism
and and and the you know and and
kind of making things happen from the
bottom up so um and i really do believe
one person can make a tremendous amount
of difference one one book one idea one
person
uh all significant change from
often
one idea
and one person's decision to to act
against the forces of history
hi
i was wondering um
what
issue or theme do you think is the
greatest challenge facing chinese
americans today
the biggest challenge today
there are many but i would say probably
the biggest challenge is the sense that
that we're still often viewed as
perpetual foreigners and not
as real americans and i think the only
way to combat that is to
as i said earlier to exercise our our
duties and our obligations and our
rights as americans we have to register
to vote regularly we have to participate
in the american process of democracy so
um
i would and we have to um
network with other groups we cannot just
i think
socialize and work with only other
chinese americans or asian americans i
think that's a very dangerous thing
iris chang's books include threat of the
silkworm and the rape of nan king
the chinese in america a narrative
history is published by viking an
imprint of the penguin group
visit
penguinputnam.com for more information
next week on history on book tv the
modern american presidency louis gould's
consideration of 20th century
585-3890 if you live in the eastern
central time zone 202 585 389 if we live
in the mountain or pacific time zone
coming out of haynes hall we are going
to ask you to join us and introduce you
to another author who is here at the
fair her name is virginia prostro hello
this is her book the substance of style
how the rise of aesthetic value is
remaking commerce culture and
consciousness and it kind of has
something to do with the panel that we
just saw the whole issue of culture and
as they were talking about a possible
culture of fear what do you think about
that idea well we we have a panel
tomorrow on aesthetics uh what's it
called aesthetics commerce and american
culture and uh you know
commerce is a very big part of our
culture
and if you talk about the culture of
fear often that's carried through the
media which is another part of our
commercial uh culture what i'm writing
about in the substance of style
is the increasing importance that we put
on the look and feel of our surroundings
the look and feel of people places and
things as a source of economic value so
for example to talk about a fear that's
out there in the world um aside from
just the general economic anxiety of any
recession there is this always when we
have a recession there's always this
great fear that this is somehow going to
be the one where there are going to be
no more jobs in the future
because we are always very aware of the
kind of jobs that are disappearing and
one of the points that i make in in the
substance of style that i've also made
in some writing i've done for the new
york times magazine and other places is
that actually when you look at aesthetic
jobs whether you're talking about
graphic designers whether you're talking
about the guys who make granite
countertops whether you're talking about
massage therapists and nail technicians
at every level
cosmetic surgeons at every level of
education and pay there is a boom
and we tend not to even notice these
jobs because they're not
the jobs we're used to and yet many
people again at every level of pay and
every level of education are making
their living enhancing the look and feel
of our surroundings now uh did you do a
lot of research for this or did you rely
on research already done i did both i
did a number of interviews uh with some
with
designers and people who work in essex
some at companies like starbucks or ge
plastics that
are using aesthetics as a strategy
and then i also relied on
social science research and economics
sociology anthropology to help me get at
this issue of what is the substance of
style what is the value that people get
from aesthetics is it there's a critique
of the market economy which i'm sure
we'll get into some in our panel uh
tomorrow which says if you buy something
if you pay more for something because
the way you like it looks
or because it has the new england
patriots on it
uh if you pay more for it it must be
that you're being fooled or you're being
tricked some way and i'm saying well
that can happen but more often it's
because of the pleasure and meaning that
you get from whatever that good or
service is and therefore that's okay and
that's okay yes and that's a normal
source of economic of evolution and for
a number of reasons economic reasons
technological reasons social and
cultural reasons uh that is becoming an
increasing import increasing source of
value in the economy let's see if we can
take some phone calls boca raton florida
hello
yes hi uh my question is
is to do whether uh whether the culture
of fear which was uh
discussed in the panel as any kind of
incipient risk to this republic
in terms of the for example the uh
culture of fear which surrounds children
and parents nowadays are very attentive
to the children and keeping them home a
great deal without allowing the children
to be out uh freely roaming and and
educating themselves in the real world
uh you know in terms of natural things
climbing trees and so on as i did as a
child and this it seems to me that this
is a pernicious um
quality and i just wonder whether uh
whether uh any on the panel would have
any idea about
whether there is any kind of incipient
risk to the society coming out of this
field issue
well let's see what virginia posture i
think that is definitely a risk and uh
it's something you uh when i was editor
of reason magazine for many years it was
something that we wrote about uh
frequently in reason the the fear uh
that leads to excessive reaction and
often uh you mentioned parents being
afraid for their children there's also
the
case where even parents would like to
let their kids go out and climb trees or
play on the jungle gym or whatever
are hampered in that pursuit because
there are so many lawsuits so you see
school playgrounds removing their play
equipment or that sort of thing so there
is a risk there i think that people
won't have the experience of of testing
their limits on the other hand at the
very same time that we see all this
overprotectiveness
we see in that very same generation the
rise of extreme sports as soon as they
get old enough to be sort of out from
under the family thumb a certain portion
of people
really enjoy taking risks and really
enjoy adrenaline
los angeles go ahead
yeah i just wanted to uh tie together to
the two panels i just saw the one with
uh tavis smiley and then the one on the
culture of fear uh tavis smiley at one
point said you know uh bush wants an
amendment on uh to ban gay marriage you
know why not an amendment that would
afford everyone or guarantee everyone
a quality education
and then with the the panel and the
cultural fear
um all our information is you know
edited and constricted by five
corporations so
uh if you're gonna make an amendment on
anything it should be for media reform
because we have to know where we're at
before we can find out where we want to
go thanks a lot
well i think that's a really good
example of the culture of fear is this
idea that in this explosion of internet
and cable and things like c-span we hear
over and over again that in the good old
days uh there was no corporate media
never mind that there were you know
three networks you can pick one and most
daily newspapers have a monopoly
i think
to the contrary we're living in an age
where people are much freer to exercise
checks on
the media that they receive and you can
see this in some of the uh very sad for
me as a journalist scandals that we have
we've seen at the new york times and at
usa today in part those came to light
because people outside the organization
said hey wait a minute there's something
wrong here and eventually it built to
the point where the
the inside the organization of people
investigated and you know hedge rolled
so that people know where you come from
you mentioned reason magazine what is it
and what point of view does it cost
reason is a libertarian magazine in the
nonpartisan
classical liberal sense i trace my
intellectual roots back to
the scottish enlightenment adam smith
david hume i've been reading a lot of
those things lately there's nothing like
18th century books to help you think
about commerce and and culture actually
and uh i have
i was editor of reason for many years
for about about 10 years nick gillespie
who is i believe a c-span of a peer
visitor from time to time nick gillespie
is my successor and uh reason does a lot
of work on cultural issues and you also
have today a website not a web but a
well i have a web blog
oh yeah we got to talk about that yes
well in 1998 when i wrote my first book
the future and its enemies i started a
website called dynamist.com which was
originally meant to be sort of a
supplement to the book if you like the
book this will give you you can check
some of my footnotes you can read some
additional material well over the years
as the internet developed the website
developed and now it is a
general site for all my work it has
stuff about the substance of style as
well as the earlier book and i have a
blog which is
a great way to comment on
everything under the sun austin texas go
ahead
they're going to fly in there austin are
you there
try austin texas one more time
are you there
go ahead
go ahead
okay well i had caller
try one more time are you there color
hawaii go ahead please
we're going to have to let them go what
are you working on now i am
working on an article for the boston
globe ideas section about the
importance of an esoteric field called
operations research which has a lot to
do with the productivity gains that
we've seen in recent years and i'm
working on a very different subject
which is the subject of glamour sort of
a spin-off of the substance of style
what is it how does it
why is it powerful and why can it be
dangerous virginia pastoral thanks very
much good luck on your panel discussion
tomorrow okay thanks a lot we are live
at the los angeles uh los angeles times
festival of books this is their ninth
annual festival and we're going to go
over here
closer and
down here so that we can chat
with irish chang
irish hi i'm connie dublin nice to meet
you welcome to book tv
thank you for holding on youtube
first of all we've just finished a panel
on culture and the culture of fear
what's your thoughts when you think
about
your topic which you usually talked
about the chinese in america and also
your historical book the rape of nanking
as it is as it looks at um our culture
today and for some people believing that
there is a culture of fear out there
there definitely is a culture of fear
and i
say that after 9 11 i mean some of the
treatment of
ethnic minorities in this country such
as muslim americans have mirrored really
the persecution that chinese americans
experienced during the exclusion era so
i think we have to constantly be aware
of some of these cycles of history and
uh the chinese america describes how
at various times
the culture of fear or
like these exaggerated fears of china
and the american imagination led to
severe backlashes against the
chinese-american immigrant population
let me show both of your books
irish chang's newest book which is out
in paperback is the chinese in america
which is what a 150-year epic saga of
the chinese immigrant experience in this
country and the fate of their
descendants and for book notes you
appeared for this book the rape of
mankind that's right and
tell people who may not be familiar with
nan king what happened the rape of name
king is the story of one of the greatest
atrocities of world history when the
japanese imperial army killed an
estimated 300 000 chinese civilians and
also committed the single greatest mass
rape of world history at that time in
the capital of china in 1937 which was
the city of nan king our phone lines
continue to be open we'd invite you to
join us 202 585-3890
if you live in the east or central time
zone 202-585-3891
if you live in the mountain or pacific
time zone let's go to the newer book the
chinese in america first of all why did
you feel you needed to tell this story
well i just felt that there was a lack
of really good and accurate information
on the chinese-american immigrant
experience there were some excellent
books on the topic but they came out
decades ago and um i i really wanted to
expose not just some of the stories the
prejudice but of the story the great
contributions of chinese americans to
the united states this should not be
seen as like a foreign or ethnic story
but rather as the quintessential
american story it's a history of the
united states itself as seen through the
perspective of one of its immigrant
groups and
i found that every generation had to
struggle for their civil liberties and
democracy in this country and it's an
ongoing struggle so there are a lot of
cautionary stories in here dallas texas
you're first up with iris chang hello
hello i wanted to say thanks c-span
if you lift up your camera
and look around at all the people around
you
we are fighting the fear the fact that
you're standing there talking to that
woman who is telling us we don't have to
be afraid
people that
write the books that tell us without
c-span you don't see this and it is what
america needs to see that these people
are not afraid
we're not afraid
we are learning
how to
assimilate all the information but there
are plenty of channels and he spans one
of them
and we thank you
thank you thank you well i i agree that
there are many ways we can get this
information out but still there's so
much information about not about
american history or the chinese american
immigrant experience that really isn't
what commonly known and that's why i
wrote the book
for example i didn't know that one in
five chinese americans in this country
during world war ii served in the us
armed forces i mean there was probably
no other ethnic group that gave so much
i mean percentage-wise of their
population to the u.s military and yet
when we have seen retrospectives on
world war ii and we look at an asian man
in a uniform we usually think of him as
a japanese enemy soldier or as you know
maybe a a chinese nationalist soldier
you know trying a foreigner and um and
there are other there's so many other
contributions as well i mean not just
the fact that for example you know that
we have had so many chinese in the
sciences and technology and the nobel
laureates but just how they laid down
the foundation of civil rights law in
this country was a really intriguing uh
development as i researched this book
for example the u.s right to birthright
citizenship was reinforced and protected
by a chinese-american lawsuit wong kim
marth versus u.s which now
means that
every american who's born on every
person who's born on american soil is a
us citizen whether or not their their
parents or their grandparents uh were
citizens or eligible for fern uh
citizenship so um and it's it's really
kind of incredible it's what
distinguishes our country from others
such such as germany or japan where you
know you the your citizenship depends on
the citizenship of your ancestors and
you've got permanent foreign
underclasses such as koreans who are
living in japan for generations but
they're not really considered japanese
citizens so um but you know i'm glad you
brought up the question of the culture
of fear because we now know that our
birthright citizenship rights have been
challenged thanks to new legislation
after 9 11. we have you know we we have
challenges to that right where that
could be strict from us if we are deemed
you know subversive or supportive of
terrorist groups so i think we have to
recognize that every generation of
americans will have to fight to uphold
our system of democracy it's an ongoing
struggle and
that's that's pretty much part of our
responsibility as americans next call
hawaii hello
yes this is hilo hawaii hello
yes aloha from hawaii
one of the comments i wanted to make to
miss chang
is that one of the things that is really
unfortunate
is that
labels are given to people
without
without proper uh
reason to do so
in other words
everybody
is a citizen of the united states if
you're born in the
united states whether you're a criminal
or a thief or whether you're in prison
or whatever malfunctions you may be
guilty of doing
and in order to be a citizen
it really requires you to act like the
citizens of the united states of america
in your proportion to be able to do so
there's really too much
emphasis put on
what a person's ancestors were
this was brought up in the last panel
discussion
in which sherbet talked about
people act like being tribal beings
one has to really
extend
one concept of what one's neighbor is in
loving thy neighbor and there is at
least one culture that advocates
i agree we have to look beyond ethnicity
to see some of the underlying human
rights issues when we talk about
upholding our american democratic system
if we're not careful
uh we could end up fractured and
balkanized as a nation and it's uh
it's it's going to be interesting in the
next few decades because by the year
2050 there will be no more dominant
racial majority in this country so we
could either evolve towards being a
nation that looks past color and race
and
ethnicity and really and focus on
character and contribution or we if
we're not careful we could
establish an elaborate racial hierarchy
like what we've seen in countries like
south
africa and um and it really is going to
depend on on the choices we americans
make when you go before chinese american
groups are you able to look them in the
eye and say
you know that the idea of identity uh
politics and the idea of identity
assimilation does not work for them well
actually whenever i'm speaking before
chinese american groups i always
emphasize especially if i hear questions
like well sometimes i feel like i'm half
american half chinese i always emphasize
no you are 100
american you can embrace your cultural
heritage like so many other ethnic
groups have done but you are still a us
citizen if you were born here and you
are entitled to all the rights and
privileges and also of course you have
to undertake all the obligations that
comes with being a us citizen we must
never forget that and i always remind
them the irs always they certainly think
of them as citizens so it's important
to exert all right so i am always
emphasizing this and that that you know
that the issue of cultural identity of
being very proud of your heritage and
also are our right
and privileges as a us citizen that
those are two very separate issues and
and uh you know
and we have to we have to do our best
really to uh to educate people about but
our system we have to be involved in
grassroots activism if if that if the
number of people the critical minority
dips below a certain level our republic
will not have a chance to survive so i'm
always i'm always emphasizing the the
importance of sustaining our american
democratic experiment it is very much a
young and fragile experiment let's take
one more call for you caller where are
you calling from
uh santa barbara
santa barbara go ahead santa barbara
yeah
ms chang um i thanks for making that
distinction between race identity and
citizenship
um my question to you is is to your
citizenship part uh
if you you know with all the problems
that are facing americans as far as
government
governance being
clogged with corporate money so to speak
would you be interested as a citizen
would you be open to the idea of a
constitutional convention
a constitutional convention to do what
color
well basically a constitutional
convention is like a national forum it's
just to propose ideas to the 50 states
and whatever ideas are proposed at the
convention if 38 states or more agree
yes this is a good idea to be put on the
constitution than it is so my question
is would you be in favor of a national
uh convention just to propose ideas and
didn't get a chance to see what everyone
thinks
i'm certainly interested in having
national dialogues and having national
forums absolutely um you know one one
thing that has constantly come out in in
my research as i've written the threat
of the silkworm the rape of nanking and
the chinese in america is really the
theme of power and the dangers of power
and and um
you know having these kinds of forms are
going to make our society safer because
the empirical research has shown that
the more concentrated the power in the
hands of a government or any kind of
ruling class elite regardless of uh you
know
the more concentrated that power
regardless of that group's race religion
or culture or any other factor that
group is more likely to commit human
rights atrocities both at home and
abroad initiate war with their neighbors
and so democracy true democracy
you know has to be championed a
diffusion of power has to be has to be
promoted in order to make our society
safer that's what the research on
genocide has shown and um
and education is one such force to
diffuse power it returns power to the
people and engaging our leaders in
dialogue
or demanding access to government
records of really kind of promoting a
marketplace of ideas all of that is
imperative to the survival of democracy
so i would absolutely uh be favor of
having national dialogues on this
subject what are you doing now i'm
actually you know i'm i'm uh i'm
continuing to do a lot of research i'm
touring right now in the country to
promote the chinese america but um i'd
like to get started on my fourth book
you know i i've spearheaded an oral
history project uh in a world war ii
world history project which just gained
institutional support and
there's like certain stories that are
emerging from that that may be great
topics for a fourth book so um and so i
would really urge people who are
interested in my research or maybe even
sharing some of their stories with me to
go to my website which is
irishchang.net.net yes thank you very
much it's nice to see you it's been a
pleasure okay take care we are
continuing our live coverage of the
ninth annual los angeles times festival
of books and what we thought we would do
now is to introduce you to the man
whose book was on the cover of the new
york times book review last week
mr ed common hello mr collins hi what is
this book this is uh blue blood
what is it it's a memoir of my nine
years in counting with the nypd and it's
got a lot of family history as well my
father was an fbi agent
in new york his brother was a cop for
over 30 years and it goes back to my
great grandfather who went on in 1907 so
it's coming up on a century in the uh in
the business how did you get to the
point of wanting to write a book about
this is this your first it's my first
book i always wanted to write i did some
writing before i uh became a cop and i
wrote a couple of articles for the new
yorker about being a cop uh that that
led to this
i was just looking at your
your pin it's a dea pin dea but that's
my union
what is it about this story that you
think resonates with people not only in
new york but across the country it's
ordinary stories of the strange things
that you see as a cop i mean that's one
of the best things about the job you're
not going to door and people got to tell
you a story
so it's the strange things that happen
every day plus it's
in new york during that period uh saw
amazing drops in crime we had over 2 000
homicides a year about 10 years ago now
it's floating around 600 so
uh
i did
a small part of that i suppose not that
much uh but it was an interesting time
to be a cop and that's an interesting
job as it is tell us this one of the
stories oh boy
quite a few of them i
i can tell you one that's not even in
the book i mean it's it's they just
happened all the time i had a uh uh
a case of a guy who had a very expensive
watch stolen he thought it was a kid who
worked for him
and
so i brought we went to see the kid and
he wasn't in and
he had an identical twin brother who
confided to us that he thought his
brother was a little crazy
and then we when we brought the uh the
kid in he's you know we denied it denied
and denied it and it turns out these
identical twin brothers have been
substituting for each other or all these
interviews so i kind of had to lock up
the whole family
there uh has been a lot of allegations
of um problems in the new york police
department how do you address them in
this book yeah i mean the controversial
cases of the 90s luima and diallo were
one was you know one one was uh an
absolute crime uh committed by a police
officer the other one was just a
terrible tragedy that i think was
an awful political football
the cops are treated very unfairly
and how do you make that distinction i
mean how how do you expect the american
public to make the distinction when we
see
issues on both sides of the fence like
you just talked about look at the facts
you got to see what happened and you've
got to be careful who's uh you know
who's saying what for what reason i mean
you have to look at what happened that's
what that's what a cop does that's what
a reporter does that's why the you know
the writing and the police work
complement each other more often than
they conflict who does some of the best
journalism on uh
on writing about police matters these
days oh the i'm about writing about cops
uh
in in new york uh we have uh
you know michael daley writes a great
deal and thoughtfully about them
it's it's hit or miss you know i'll give
you back your book this is the book blue
blood
the author is edward conlon thanks very
much thanks for uh thanks for having me
good luck
we are live at the los angeles times
festival of books we are just going to
be
taking a look around and give you an
idea of what some of the things coming
up during the night the rest of the
afternoon first of all
in just a few moments we're going to
take you live in back into the hanes
auditorium where there's going to be a
panel called what's that sound the 60s
revisited the guest will be douglas
brinkley the author of tour of duty john
kerry and the vietnam war mr brinkley's
newest biography on john kerry mark
kurlansky will be there his the author
of 1968 the year that rocked the world
neil gordon the author of the company
you keep jeffrey cohen the author of see
no evil the backstage battle over sex
and violence in television will be the
moderator and another one of the
speakers will be david maranist who
wrote they marched into sunlight warren
peace vietnam and america october 1967.
mr marianis is up for one of the awards
tonight the la times festival of the
books will be giving out awards tonight
uh just the back of us in uh royce hall
and uh we'll know a little bit more
about who those awards are and we'll be
able to tell you about them tomorrow in
our last segment tonight please stay
with us because we're going to take
phone calls for lou cannon liu cannon
wrote the book of course about lots of
books actually on ronald reagan he has
written a lot of biographical work but
his newest work is about ronald reagan
in this state and how that was the
beginnings of his national career so all
of that coming up today and then we'll
be live again here tomorrow uh there's a
280 exhibitors and also quite a few
other people uh exhibiting and writing
and so we will take you back inside
haynes auditorium now
for our live coverage of this next panel